What does that thing you say when
you clink glasses instead of sure.
It's like the Irish, you
know, salute or, or you know,
now stroll Vi's just the Irish
version of Sloucher. [inaudible] yeah,
like slash l. H. I. N. T.
E I believe his house about
Nate [inaudible]. Ooh,
I never knew that you said it before and
always just let it slide cause I didn't
want to seem like a Dork. Yeah, I know.
That's one of the things you probably
seen it real book. I mean like, you know,
Gaelic is some real harsh. Yeah. Like uh,
vowels and Haley, it's a crazy,
like I've seen Gaelic names that like
were spelled insane and it was, oh,
that's pronounced Shawn.
Like some crazy shit.
Like that wild ancient language,
right? Yeah. For real though.
I love Irish people, men, I just,
I'm fucking fascinated by
the wildness of that culture.
That's what God made whiskey,
you know? So the Irish would put,
so the Irish would never rule the world.
When you see it got like
a guy like Conor McGregor,
that part of what is him is Irish.
He's like a pure like brilliant Irish.
You know what I'm talking for sure.
Bowls fall the way motherfucker
knows how to take a loss,
knows how to take a loss. Takes a loss
like a man and still talk shit. You know,
come right back to him. It's like
that, you know that that guy that you,
your fight,
but he loses but you know you're going
to have to fight him tomorrow. Yes.
Or as soon as his shit is healed
up into busted up, this is gone.
It's kind of like a hundred million
dollars in the bank and he still wants to
fight people still smacking people
at bars. Yeah, that's, that's, it's
hard. It's hard to be like,
don't do that. Nah, not that.
Oh, who knows what the
fuck the guy said to him,
but it looked like the
guy was old as fuck.
Someone said he was only 50 that the guy
was only 50 do didn't fold up though.
He just kind of sat at the bar counter.
Didn't really, yeah, he smacked him.
He gave him this smack in the back and
then like a couple of fingers he touched
you do what we call mushed him.
He pushed him. He like, yes,
you can kind of be interpreted as
hitting, but it really ain't quite a hit.
You know when you're a guy like that,
you're basically walking around agreeing
not to fuck people up because you have
to kind of agree to not fuck
people up. The money's got,
there should be like five guys around
him that makes sure that never happens,
but they can't listen to him.
Like if you have a guy like him,
he's going to do whatever he wants.
Even if there's a bunch of
people around him stopping him,
you're not going to stop
him from doing checks.
When he threw that guy's phone down
the ground, stomped it in Miami,
there was all the body guards there.
He just did it. He just did it.
He's Kinda McGregor.
He's fucking, look you.
He's living like you're supposed to live.
If you Conor McGregor the dances, dog,
go to jail. Dude. Don't get locked down.
The whole structure of the way things
are now as far as like entertainment,
it's like, yeah, it's all about eyeballs.
While he fucking figured it
out, man, pulling out figs, you
know what I mean? He figured it out, man,
like in the most crazy way possible.
He figured out how to just blow up
the whole system. When you're in,
you're a guy who has
been fighting. I mean,
I contacted him on Twitter
in like 2013 right?
By 2018 he's worth $100 million quick
and he calls it all the way and
he calls it all the way. It's,
that's the craziest part is
he called it all the way like,
I'm going to be a billionaire
or a multimillionaire.
You know what Dana White said to
me once about him that's dead on.
He said he eats pressure. He said, that
guy eats pressure. He just eats it.
He goes, he just, he just goes in there
and the more pressure experiences,
the better he can perform. It's true.
It's like you look at the Aldo fight
picture, perfect left-hand knockout.
I mean it doesn't get any prettier.
The timing, the setup, the patients,
the movement that the setting it up,
looking for them to leap in and buying,
catching the money's coming in.
Pretty sure he said exactly those.
That's exactly what he said he was
gonna do right before the fight too. Oh,
that's me tweeting him.
January of 2013 I saw his fight in,
I think it was cage warriors.
I think that's the promotion.
Cage wars or cage warriors. I think
it's, why am I fucking that up?
Cage wars. Is there two different
ones? There probably is.
It's probably a bunch of
cage stuff, but either way,
he was a fucking people up overseas
and I was like, this kid is for real.
He just sees something. Sometimes
he sees like, I'll watch a video,
I'll see how a guy moves. I'm like,
Jesus, some guys just have something.
And he had just ridiculous
timing. So relaxed in there.
Those were fun. Frakes man,
his early days of MMA is like,
you can go back and watch him and you
go, oh, this guy's gonna be special.
He's gotta like a weird sense
of timing. You know? He's like,
he's just very good at understanding
where you're at and knowing how to put it
into his head. Me winning, you know the
Irish, the whole Irish thing. That's it.
Oh for sure. Man. Persian. Love it.
I love it. Yeah. When he was
like, we all fight together,
like do when he's in the room,
like if he wins a fight and there's,
you know the crowds filled with like
7,000 Irish people. Do you feel it?
Like you feel like goosebumps. It's crazy.
Like you do everything you can to stop
it just to keep yourself from crying at
the beauty of it.
This guy standing there in
front of thousands of people
that have flown overseas
to see us. Finally people fly
over for, Ooh, it's crazy.
They take over the fucking Vegas hotels
take off her like where you have seas.
Then they shut down like
seventh avenue in front of,
in front of the Madison Square.
There's not a fucking fan on earth
like Irish fans. They're different.
I used to think Brazilian fans were
crazy until I saw the Irish fans.
They take over the whole Mandalay
bay was taken over by people singing.
It was all, I was fair amount
of drinking. Oh, fair. More than fair.
But just the fact that they could do that,
that they can gang get together
and sing the same song,
like thousands of them
together singing the same song.
I remember the first time, uh,
when we went to Ireland
as house of pain and, uh,
in between songs, they broke into the
whole, you know, the soccer chance stuff.
And we were just like, whoa,
this is crazy. You know,
we never experienced anything
like that. They don't, they had,
you didn't do that at the sports events
at home back then? Not back then at all.
So that was amazing. Culturally,
it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's that soccer.
They have to have real Conor fight in
Ireland once he's got a fight in Dublin,
in a soccer stadium.
Fuck yet. Right. Why not?
Why not? If he's ever gonna fight
again, that's what it's trying to do it,
I don't, you know, the, I think the, I,
the idea was that it's like more money
in paper view. If you fight in Vegas,
you know Vegas is worth a lot of money.
Doesn't the time have a lot to do
with it too? When the European thing,
they gotta do the whole weird time thing
over there so they can accommodate the
pay per view here. Yeah,
it'd be real weird.
They'd be fighting like
four in the morning.
It's always real weird to me when I
wake up and there's like a a a South
American fight that happened
at noon and I'm like, Oh God,
missed or Japan like rise in if you
trying to watch rise and they have it in
Japanese time. That's
how pride used to be.
We would get up at like we would have
guys come over my house and we would watch
pride at like three
o'clock in the morning.
Like sometimes they would have
them live for some reason,
if I'm remembering it correctly.
Sometimes they would have them live and
sometimes they'd have the fights and you
knew what happened but you didn't get
to see it for like a couple of weeks.
They would delay it in North America
for some strange reason. They didn't,
didn't, didn't totally do it live.
I was hip to that MMA share
thing a long time ago.
They always had the bootleg videos and
I tell anybody that's like Voldemort.
Don't say that. I don't did I
did. I just mess up. I don't know.
You can get mad. It was gone.
Anyways. That was 10 years ago. Dude.
Illegal street dude,
UFC is gangsters with that.
Like it used to be you could watch
those and then I over time you was like,
cause like in Europe before,
like there was things like
fight pass and thing like that.
You couldn't find a paper view if you
were stuck over there four in the morning,
in the middle of somewhere.
So you would lean on whatever you could
as a fan and, but the, they start,
you started seeing them shutting them
down. Like it doesn't, they're gangsters.
The UFC or gangsters. Yeah.
So it's a big money business.
People fucking be oppressive
is what it is. It's impressive.
It's like there's like a, there's a army
of motherfucker somewhere going and go.
Yeah. Some of it must get through, right.
Just every at the internet just
has stuff that gets, I don't know.
I got the fight pass now
so I everywhere I go.
So I got the fight pass and the
little you have that little um,
static IP address though. Like when
you are out the country you can,
it's perfect. That's perfectly
normal. You know what's weird?
Why aren't they showing why?
Like I need to ask the UFC this.
Why don't they show like the height,
like the knockouts on
their Instagram page.
They show when the knockouts
over and you notice that? Yeah,
I do not understand. I don't understand
it because once everybody knows,
they know, everybody knows. They know
it's not hurting anybody to watch it.
I get it. It'll just hype up the
replay business. A lot of business.
I wonder what the replay buys are like
the cats who just missed it and bought
the replay. Maybe that
factors, I'm sure they cry.
Make a nice second round of
money on that replay. Right?
Like so how long do you think they should
hold off for like a week or two maybe?
Yeah, a week. A week. And then put the
highlights on. Sure. Do they do that?
Did they ever show,
I get this weird impression that they
only show like right after the finish on
the Instagram now know they have, they'll
show entire fights on Instagram now,
but old fights like all the fights. Yeah,
so like pretty sure they showed
steep bay just pulling off of DC.
Was that the case? That was a crazy,
I got my whole phone got blown up cause
apparently I'm right in the background
when that happens. Like
going, I don't know,
I haven't seen it but my phone blew
up right there. That fight was chaos.
That would fight was Kay. I was fun.
I had an amazing time. That car,
I should say the car fight card was chaos.
That was a wild one man and a Anaheim.
It was hard watching TC get hit
with those fucking body shots.
That was dude. As soon as he started
pigging in it was like, oh wow,
something's happening dude. Steve Bay's
nasty. He wanted that belt by shots.
He took incredible know.
We were talking about Yo the shots Steve
Bay took and just walked through him
like wow.
It was crazy because DC managed to put
him away with one punch the first time
and say you didn't see coming,
you didn't see it coming.
Everything you got hit with was hard
as hell. But he saw it all coming. Yup.
And he let them get in that little right
in his chest area wet cause that's what
he got that short one
on him that last time.
And that's exactly what
happens if you're not prepared.
If you don't think you're going to get
punched and you relax for a minute and
then you get punched by something you
don't see coming, you can get fucked up.
And um,
when you're in a fight with a Greco
Roman wrestler of the caliber of DC knows
how to manipulate you.
And he just had been manipulated
in perfectly into that right hand.
And it was a beautiful work of art,
but he was never able to hit him
like that in the second fight,
like as cleanly and have
that kind of an effect.
The shots he hit him with were
pretty good shots. But Steve,
I ate them and then you realize, oh,
Steve Bay could take a fucking shot.
He just got clipped. He just got
caught. He could take a fucking shot.
And he was there in the fourth
round, which is really impressive.
Like in the fourth round, he was
looking good. He recognizes him.
As soon as he touched that in
that liver shot that it was wow.
Something happened there and it hit him.
He dug in like four or
five straight times.
Man cannot let a guy like that punch
you in the lever that many times.
I'm sure DC obviously didn't want him to
do that, but that's how good Steve is.
It was like the DC though. Yeah.
Respect to DC. I love that guy. Agrees.
He's one of my favorite people to do
commentary with. Man for sure. He's,
he's the best. He's so fun.
He's hilarious. Like when
thought when Rose Naama,
Eunice, uh, knocked out a
Yani and j check and he's like
[inaudible] that like, that
is what I love. Like he's,
those are forever moments where, you know,
he's so free that in the
middle of like this car,
we're calling a world
title fight. He's just DC.
He could be himself and it's a,
he's got a great personality man,
and he's in a hell of a fighter and
he was dominating in the first round.
She think he's gone. He
go, he gone go fight again.
Probably he's going to want to fight
steep again if I guess, if I really guess.
I mean if he wants to do it again,
he's going to want to fight.
[inaudible] cause he's gonna want to
what? I think the way he described it as,
right that wrong that he did.
He just didn't fight well,
he didn't listen to his corner. Um,
I think that's what he thinks. Um,
it's like he fought really well in the
first round and then Bob Cook was yelling
at him in the second round, keep
your damn hands up, you know?
And he was like walking him down,
like almost like disdainfully
like walking him down.
And I don't know if that
was part of strategy to
psychologically put up a lot of
pressure on Steve Bay, you know, to
try to establish that's DBAs done that.
He's the champ now, but it
was almost like disdainful.
But Steve Bay survived so and he just
was there and he was in there and really
good shape and rounds
three in rounds, four.
That was what was really
impressive about it. I was amazed,
especially after getting fucked up quite
a bit in that first round. I mean I,
there was a couple of times where I
thought he was going to be fit. Like,
like dude, what's going to get him?
DC was all over him in that
first round and when he,
when he picked him up and
dumped him, you're like,
Jesus Christ [inaudible] Jesus Christ.
He's good. He just didn't maintain it.
That's exactly what it was. And then
Steve Bay made the adjustment and um,
you know, who the fuck knows?
He might decide, you know what,
my body doesn't want to
do this anymore. I'm done.
I know he made a ton of money and I know
he's really good as a commentator and
he'll, he'll do that forever for sure.
Or he might don't want
to do it one more time,
but then there's always John Jones,
Roy lurking, man, John, John,
you haven't felt like everybody knows
like that's the biggest rivalry in MMA,
isn't it? Isn't it? Yeah. I
mean the only thing you got,
like if you're going to talk
about accolades of of Cormey A's,
he has everything, all those champions,
but there's the little asterisk on the,
on the light heavyweight belt that he
never really got it from Ryan John,
but that's the weird part about it,
right? It's like when you're a champion,
but to champion who's the real champion
didn't lose it and then they have an
interim champ. Like
what are we doing here?
What has happened is he got an accurate,
John never come back and shown
that he's still him like,
and hopefully God willing for him keeping
all this stuff together and there's,
yeah,
it would have been different if he just
kind of fade into the distance then.
Then it changes that narrative.
But he came back and he,
his original thing was like, you
that guy. I'm that guy still. Yeah.
It was crazy. I mean, dude, that's
how crazy good John is. Really?
That's how crazy good John is.
I'd love to see that though.
And the way DC was able to beat
rumble twice rumbled to me,
it was always that smart too, Scott.
That's my dude. That's my dude.
He's so ferocious. His punching.
It's so fucking explosive, man.
He's just got so much power.
When he knocked out Glover to share
it with one punch, I was like, God.
Like who though? When I
first met him, he was,
he was a much smaller dude
when he's 2170 yeah. Yeah.
He used to work out with some friends
of mine that we used to work out in this
little MMHG and it was off
Melrose and, and Labrea,
I think it was called l a m m a at the
time or something like that. And He,
before he wound up in Colorado,
I think, you know. But you know,
I've known him through the
wild man. He's a good dude,
meticulously powerful and
he's a really nice guy. Yeah,
it's good to his fucking powers.
Preposterous though. Like,
but it was him and then when I seen him
come back in to two oh five that's what
I was, yeah, just mine. I was like,
what the people at two oh five but
it was interesting man. It's his,
his retirement was like one of
the most honest and like a f.
It was like, he was like happy
with it cause he was like, man,
I'm not a fighter. I'm my athlete. I
just, I'm just good at this. I was like,
wow, that's really, that's,
that's interesting. Interesting.
Waitrose weed now and raises dogs
and like spreads fringe bulldogs.
She just had it grappling competition
against this Guy Craig Jones, who's this?
A Brazilian Jujitsu guy from
Australia that's a murderer,
is a leg lock specialist to
an economy in a leg lock.
It's crazy to see how big he is.
Rumbles like fucking, I don't know,
he's gotta be like 260 pounds.
Like No. Bullshit was huge.
I seen him. We sat next to a fight.
If life not the last fight I went to
whatever the one last week before that in
Vegas probably. He looks like a
fucking super heavyweight. He's so big.
It's ridiculous. Yeah.
He just not even thinking about
losing weight for fighting anymore.
I would wonder what would happen if you
decided to come back as a heavyweight,
like no bullshit as a
heavyweight. If that guy, I mean,
you know crazy would be if that guy
wound up winning the heavyweight title,
like you're thinking of the rumble career.
He wins the ultimate fighter as a one
70 gets all the way up to one 85 can't
make one 85 misses weight. Right.
Misses it for the veto of Belfort fight,
I believe. A big fight.
Then he goes up the light heavyweight
even goes up to heavyweight foot beat
Andre or Lawsky in,
I think it was the PFL and I
think it really beat him badly.
If I remember correctly, it
got broke. He broke his jaw so,
and then that was at heavyweight.
That was at heavyweight in the PFL.
It wasn't in the UFC and then
it comes back to the UFC.
It comes back to the UFC as
a light heavyweight and just
line and people see him hit people.
They just go, Whoa, that guy. Scary.
Tiny too. Excellent timing. You know he,
it was just power rumble Johnson UFC
return could be on cards if the price is
right. Yeah. That was when [inaudible].
This is from recently? Yeah, after
his grappling matching thing. Yeah,
July two months ago. Two months
ago. It's so big right now.
I would think you'd fight
heavyweight heavyweight.
Him and I mean I really
think he's Harriman's tpa.
He was torturing his body for so long
to make one 70 I never saw anybody lose.
When you got two 78
that's a hundred pounds
over where he fought.
It is a 100 pound gain that is so crazy.
A hundred pounds more than what he weighed
in when he won the ultimate fighter.
That's insane. That's
insane. God bless. Oh God.
Two 78
oh my God. 170 on my God.
He was 170 170 pound champion
becomes a 278 pound heavyweight.
And it tells us like, where did he,
how did you do that? Where is it?
It's crazy. That guy's power is
fucking undeniably preposterous.
What do you make of Brock? Uh, try
to pick a fight with John Ball. Oh,
that's so silly. That's
not, let's just talk.
What else can I say about a rumble?
Is that even though rumble was that,
that good and that scary DC
handled that man DCAD a hard shot.
Got Him to the ground. That was rumbold
he's one seventies very thin now he's,
he know her most,
but d c was the guy who managed to handle
that and that d c is seemingly easily
say pawn. He was the only
one that can handle him.
I didn't think that was going to go
that way. Like I said, that was my dude.
So I was rooting heavy for him. Wow. D's.
He's a special guy when it
comes to wrestling. He's
especially talented and um,
I think wrestlers, they know where
they stand in the wrestling food chain.
And when you get gripped by a
dude like DC, like, oh Jesus,
this is a Olympic caliber
wrestling, that's beast mode.
He just started smashing and he was able
to run his way through the heavyweight
division. You've got to realize
before he lost his steep a fight,
he'd only lost one round ever at
heavyweight. Really? Arguably.
And that was to Josh Barnett.
I think that was like one round
that he lost on the cards.
And Josh Barnett is a, you know, a legend,
a fucking the youngest ever [inaudible]
the youngest ever UFC heavyweight
champion. Josh Barnett,
brilliant guy to do.
You know Josh got personally no
fucking brilliant guy, brilliant guy.
So that's the last round
the DC had ever lied,
lost like one round as a heavyweight.
He was just dominating people with
his wrestling and his hand speed.
He was just fucking people up. But it
just, that's how good Steve Bay is, man.
People slept on steep bay. You know,
people thought the DC was
going to run him over again.
Like you've ran him over the
first time. And, uh, you know,
I think DC prepared for a long and arduous
fight, but Steve pays a big, big man,
big giant heavyweight man. He's a long,
tall dude along frame and DC weighed
more than him during the fight.
I think he weighed like six pounds
more than them, something like that.
But it's just built, it's a
just, just very different way.
Come in like 20 or 30 pounds. Last
and last time he came in less. Yeah.
I don't know if it was 20
pounds, but I think it was,
he was like two 30 in this fight. I
think DC was two 36. So DC came in,
light two came in lighter
than their first fight.
But I think uh, you know, Steve,
Pete came in after like a whole
year of waiting for this rematch.
Like trying to figure it out
if it's ever going to happen.
Is DC gonna Fight Brock
Lesnar and Jesus, you know,
it's like he was always waiting and then
finally they gave him the chance to see
him. I hate to see DC lose. I
hate it. It's hard to watch, man.
He's such a nice guy. It's, it's hard.
As much as I liked that guy
to see him get hit, it's hard.
But you take all that stuff out and
just look at it as two athletes.
And what Steve Bay did was just brilliant
that the whipping of that left hook to
the body was just textbook
man tax book. Do you see,
was fighting an amazing fight up until
that, until that he gassed a little bit.
It looked like to me and the liver shots
started happening. You know, it's also,
you got to appreciate the technique the
way Steve Bay through that left Hook was
perfect. I mean it was just,
these are brilliant shots.
There's no wasted movement. The technique
was pinpoint. I mean he just wack.
He just ripped some in there and he caught
DC standing there and he just hit him
with a hard left to the body. And then
once he realized he could do that more,
he just continued what they were doing
and then he would go do it again and he
got in again and then now dcs in a little
bit of trouble and now he's got to,
he was going to try to do, take him down.
Like he's in this spot where it's kind
of still standing with him and he's not
down but he's hurting and
so it's how much is he hurt?
He mean he got hit with
hard body shots by the way.
Definitely letting it be known.
Those are brutal and then boom,
he starts hitting him up to
the head and drops them. Wow.
That was super impressive. Like
when you're calling a fight,
how often are you looking here and how
often do you like depends on what I can
see. I mean what you're saying is a
monitor. Yeah, it depends on how often.
Like I want to see it. If I
could just see. Absolutely.
That's why I'm just curious
like you're in PR. I'm not even,
I'm just saying a percentage wise.
If you were to guess what is,
what about a third of the time here
looking at this and the rest of time you
probably up here? Yeah, maybe
less than a third on the monitors.
I try to stay off the monitors, the
monitors, all I want to see, you know,
I want to see what's happening, but
they're like, if they're off to the side,
like pressed up against the cage,
then I kind of have to go to the
monitors because I need to see like I'm
comparing it to like an experiences
like ringside experience where I'm like,
how often I'm like about a third of the
time I feel like I'm looking at watching
the screen and the screens, you know
what I mean? Just because I want to,
there are there on the ground and I
want to see what's going on with her,
with the arm that I can't see. You know
what I mean? That kind of thing. Yeah.
Yeah. It's a wild fucking sport, man.
So while I was trying to
figure it out the other day,
I think I've been the like maybe 60
UFC. He's, man, Jeez,
surprise. I think so dude.
If I think back to the years and when I
met Dana and chuck and like ever since
that day, it's like anyone, I called up
and you know, I'm, I'm blessed and that,
you know, I get to go. And when I was
single dude, I, you know, when I was,
when it was those days, it
was a whole different game.
I'd be at almost every one cause
a lot, most of them were in Vegas.
So it would be, uh, it would
be easy to get there. Yeah.
Those are fun experiences, man.
Trying to figure out how to pull up
on Abu Dhabi, man. Are you really,
I'm trying and I'm trying to figure out
do I just buy a ticket and go or do I
figure out how so yo,
any promoter out there that
wants to Mudd jump around action,
Holler at me. You know what I mean?
I'm just trying to pull up on the
Abu Dhabi fight and have that,
I'm going to be watching
that one from here.
We're going to probably do
a fight companion for that
and one day I want to be
invited to one of those. You got to come
to one of those. Those are ridiculous.
Yeah. No that's their foreign trust. Try
not to get into conspiracies. No, no,
I'm, I'm well aware. Try to keep
anywhere from the Illuminati. Right.
This is the only way it goes south. But
even that it's fun. It's always fun.
It's like the best thing in the world is
like watching fights with friends and,
and laughing. No, I've watched it.
Good combination of things. Yeah.
It's a fun thing. My most
favorite way to watch fights,
turn the fan down at the
house. Y'all up. You man,
you could say things you
just can't say. You know,
you could talk about things you
absolutely never otherwise talk about it.
And you could describe
things with language, like
the whole, all the language.
You could use all the language. You know
like when I'm doing the UFC for shit,
like little kids are listening to
this, which is kind of weird, right?
Like if you say fuck, that's bad.
But if they watch someone get beat,
the fighter can say it though.
I mean, you know what I mean?
The fighter could say it. Yeah.
I think our think appropriately
and intelligently placed.
It wouldn't be out of line, but you
couldn't overdo it or overuse it.
It would have to be like, you'd
have to like pick that. Perfect.
The problem is it,
it gets in the way of
uh, doing the commentary,
right. You're just,
any decision that you would make to use
that kind of language would get in the
way. The commentary because
it, it would be like,
it would be less effective. Like
they would go, ah, this guy.
Like why do you have to
use it? They're true.
And they'd be like judgment of like,
when do you use it, why you use it? It's,
and then they would like think less of
what you have to say or be upset by what
you have to say. And that
would be the number one thing.
If you're trying to do commentary,
the number one thing you're trying
to do is take yourself out of it.
Like I'm trying to do that.
I'm just trying to like use the best
language possible to express my excitement
for what we're about to see. Like
this is what's important to me.
Like I just wanna I'm fucked.
This is how fucking pumped I am.
These guys are murderers. This is going
to be fascinating to see. Yo Romero.
Paulo Kosta,
what the fuck? That's exactly what we
were talking in the car on the way down.
I was watching that fight like
this, like this. This is me.
Like Jason's like it's like one of
those fights we just waiting for some
Creighton did, did the beatings. They
were giving each other. It was crazy man.
Fucking too chiseled.
Granted looking motherfucker
in a Gucci model.
Going to be in a Gucci
model ad next week for sure.
And she doesn't put pick him up
there. Crazy. The guy's beautiful.
They're both giant beautiful men with
the incredible bodies. It was a man.
The fight was fucking fantastic and it
was so highly skilled that Paula Kosta
guy is for real man. He's for
real. If he can do that too.
Yo l if he could stay on top of Yo
l like that Yo else explodes on.
Everyone explodes on everyone.
But that dude weathered the storm.
He weathered the storm and
he landed some great shots.
It was a very close fight though,
cause EOL hit him with some big shit too
and EOL took him down twice. You know,
we were, we were, you know,
it was my 50th sat Sunday so we were
out Saturdays and Sundays already again.
Oh, slideshow. [inaudible] yes sir.
It's lunch. Yeah. So like, you know,
we were going Yo old guy rep, you know
what I mean? You know, for the rep,
for the old guys, you know. And so
we were going hard for yo out bro.
He wins best body at
42 all over the world.
The guy's a monster. I mean who,
who has more like athletic length
of their elite career than UL?
Because at 42 he still moves like he
moved 10 years ago. Is he 42 two is it,
you know what I'm saying?
Cuban birth certificate
fee like 48 you know what,
that's what they say about
that. Louis or t's guy,
you know that elite
heavyweight boxer from Cuba.
[inaudible] trouble from all my
friends, Cuban friends for that.
[inaudible] my ball Cypress guy.
I had him on the podcast
with Joey Diaz translating.
It was amazing man to hear
him tell his stories in Cuban.
I just wish I spoke Spanish. I could
understand it like coming from his mouth,
but having Joey translate it and talk
about all the shit that he had to deal
with coming up through the Cuban
amateur sisters in your pocket.
Look at that dude. I gotta
Watch it cause I don't,
I don't want that one got bought
and built. That is preposterous.
That is one of them sculpted things
you buys at toys r us, right?
[inaudible] that's an action figure
for sure. Look like a real live human.
He's so bad, man.
That is so freakishly athletic
and so powerful. And you know,
it's that Cuban wrestler
system and he, he just,
the way he described it as like
[inaudible] new and doing my chain,
you just become a fucking machine. And
that's what he is with competition.
He's just a machine man. Yeah, he was
clowning too in the second two rounds.
Like that's why I was like,
Kinda felt like, you know,
we was trying to get that guy to
be emotional and make a mistake.
You don't for sure. But it was like
he again, he finished, he got here.
I mean he got the best of him
in those two rounds in my book.
I thought he wanted close, close. Not
Bad enough to be like bitching about it,
but like I would've flipped
the 29, 28 personally. Well,
the audience agreed with you when
they, uh, they were crazy. Yeah.
Which is unfortunate because Paula Kosta
just fought and amazing fight and he
has to feel like shit during the, the
post [inaudible] it sucks. I don't,
I don't condone bullying any
of that stuff that doesn't,
that most of the people that would
be, would never get in that ring.
I would never get in that
ring. You ain't got no money.
I got and I've made a lot
of money and I'd kind of,
McGregor hasn't gotten enough
money from your kid. Okay.
You got the a hundred billion. Yeah,
man. I'm like my consciousness, you know,
I'm not getting in with Mike
Tyson for any money, you know,
cause the problem is there's a lot of
recipients on the wrong side of things.
For sure. The problem is they're blowing
the decision. It wasn't his decision.
It was thought as hard out and it
wasn't that ridiculous as my point too.
Like it was like I would have
flipped it, but hey, okay. No, it's,
I can see how that could be seen 100%.
And you're a guy who has been
live to 60 fucking you. Fcs. Yeah.
Let's just, um,
I don't know what the woo thing is that's
happened in the last couple of years.
Woo. Like it's just like the whole
crowd starts, it's just like,
I just get excited. That's new. That's
like, I wasn't around a long time ago.
Anyway, some soccer thing, they probably
stole it from soccer spoon. It's like,
it's like animals answering each other and
communicating by with the wounds.
Dude, I never even thought of that.
That's so true. The Woo. That's
a new thing. Yeah. I mean, no,
that's five or six. Yeah. Right. What
was that like? It started when it,
you know what?
When's the first time it popped up
down south like a Kentucky or a North
Carolina? That's when I feel
like I heard it first like,
you know that might be Rick
flair. That might be a wreck.
It might be a ric flair. Is that
what that is? Oh yeah man. Dude,
that would make a lot now you fucking
solved the mystery for me that I'd make.
That would make sense if we can get
some confirmation on that. Somehow.
Someone asked this question
on Reddit. Someone says,
you've been talking about Rick Flair
so much that they might've picked it up
from you.
I don't know if this is some bizarro
moment where it all connected like,
oh shit. I started that. Listen, guys
like that are important to America.
That guy's such, he's such a
character in his prime with his suits.
Jet Flying Alligator,
wherein I was a WCW guy, man,
and Rick flare was the
man dude. He was a like,
he's a character that made his way
into what a thousand rap songs.
How many rap songs have Rick do?
There's a whole like, like, um,
hip hop subculture involved
with wrestling. Like, I mean,
I, I was like these cats that I'm,
we're actually fans of Westside,
Gunn and Conway and this kid penny, they
got this record label called Grizelda,
but the,
the west side gun kid is like
a fucking wrestling fanatic.
Like is more like, he's like involved.
I think he's involved with like the
WWE like doing merge and stuff like that.
Cause I see him putting shit together
that's like definitely gotta be licensed.
So Yo, it's,
there's this whole subculture of
like this of wrestling and, and,
and hip hop going on right now.
So it's definitely made its way into
standup to now, you know, they have this,
uh, podcast, the store horseman where
they all just talk about pro wrestling,
a bunch of comics, Tony Hinchcliffe
and these comments. Who,
who's on that store? Horsemen. Jeremiah
walk-ins, right? Who else? No, he's not.
I'm giving out false fake news.
Fake News. That's fake news. Um,
but it's not fake news and this
delicious, by the way. It's very good.
It's delicious. Buffalo Trace. I
ain't mad at companies from 1773 son.
They started in 1773 did you really
tell sold whiskey during prohibition for
additional medicinal purposes? I didn't
know that. Well, I didn't, but I would,
I'm not shocked at this company.
Kept making whiskey all through the
prohibition. Legally or illegally.
Yeah. From medicine. So people that, you
know, I'm gonna need a little medicine.
I just got a slew of new
whiskeys. Here it is birthday.
It's a Tony Hinchcliffe, Johnny
[inaudible], Curtis, Matt Edgar,
Josh Martin. That's right. I hope
I said it's Curtis's last name.
Ryan does that. Right? So I say that
sounds like it. Yeah. Anyway. Um,
so comics are really into pro wrestling
too. They even go live. These dorks,
they fly out to like Wrestlemania and
they go in the audience name live. Same,
same, same, same. Yeah. It's
become like a, not like a,
it's become a thing
that people like to do,
like to go to these big wrestling
events and groups of people,
whether it's musicians or
rappers, hip hop or stand ups.
They're going like for sure.
Experiencing it. Yeah, exactly.
It's like the concert experience.
Why are rappers rappers so
obsessed with Rick Flair?
Because he's got like 40 rolodexes
that one famous rant that
he went on limousine riding.
Jet Flying. Exactly. You
know that kind of sure.
All eight when that
happened and they saw, yes,
that's everything I want
and in the universe it's
insane. Yeah. You see him now.
I mean the guy still gets love
everywhere. He goes, you know,
like I did in my special where I said,
you know Rick Flair and then I put
the microphone out to the audience.
The audience goes, Woo, Julie's,
you started that shit then dude,
you started the wounds.
I don't think I did.
I think it was already going on. I
think everybody appreciates this guy.
It's like as you get up, we can't
play this right. We get in trouble,
but this is the, as you, you
know, you get older, you,
you see things like this,
you appreciate them for what they are
like you could think they're cheesy when
you're young, but then as you get older
you go, damn, that's fucking awesome.
The fact that that guy is this task
as earth. Amazing, beautiful golden
mullet when those crazy sunglasses saying
this all saying all this nutty show,
pinky ring dude man, that's an
artist. That guy's an artist.
Look at us. That's the male soap opera
forever. Since back when children, man,
you know what I mean?
When I was a kid it was Bob Backlund and
Jimmy superfly snuck a and iron chic.
I don't know if you could have really
grown up in America as a little boy and
not had a phase at some point where
you interacted with one of these rounds
where your organization's WCW or WWF when
I was growing up and if you were like
one of those kids is really into like
all music and indie groups, you know you,
you would go for some like fucking
killer Kowalski Shit. You talk to taker,
you would go, you would try to find some
people that were off the beaten path.
Like do you know about this
wrestling organization?
Cause there's a bunch of like
weird little tiny dude when I was,
when the house of pain like was like
early on. Like, you know, but you know,
we were already experiencing
pretty good success.
Like ECW had formed a crazy
extreme championship wrestling.
I think that's what it stood for out of
Philadelphia and they invited us to a
bunch and it was the
first time I ever really,
and I know it had happened before,
but their whole show was
about cats cutting their
faces open and bleeding during
matches and shit. It was insanity man.
And they had packed houses. I mean,
I think dude bought it up like Vince
McMahon bought it up and the guy who owned
it or ran it became one of the like
characters within it that I believe I've,
it's been a long time. I'm old now.
I'm 50 do you see what Ronda Rousey did
to her finger? I saw that yesterday.
How about that man? They glue that thing
together and she went back to work.
How about if I read it
right? She finished the tape.
She finished the take and ignored it
until it was over and they overshadows how
bad it was. Guys. She
goes to the hospital,
they put it back together again and then
she goes back and finishes gangster.
Dude. That's dedication. Not a
lot of humans. It's also like,
I don't want to fight anymore. I'm
going to go finish this movie. You know,
nobody wants to cut the weight
once they're done, went on.
I don't want to come back to that shit.
That's just the mindset of an
elite combat sports for short.
She just had that mindset.
There's not a whole lot of humans
that would dealt with that that way.
That's crazy. The ladies
made out of bullets.
I'm going on my workman's comp from
my sad gaff co-insurance and yeah,
you're shutting down production son.
We ain't finishing no scenes. What?
Chopped off a superstars
finger. Yeah, Jesus Christ.
What if she lost her finger? What if
it was like, I mean, how far? I mean,
it wasn't fall. I mean, yeah,
that's a fuck without the,
the super expert surgeons that's gone.
Speaking of which do last
last, I think it happened.
I don't know if we talked about it and
it might've been after the last time it
was on. Dude.
So I'm on a trip and I'm coming home
literally about to get on the plane and I
get this text from my
wife. Like I'm, I'm at the,
I got a, I chopped off my finger
and I'm like, in my head I'm like,
she didn't chop off her
finger meds. I cut her,
probably got pretty rowdy but stitches.
I was like, okay, it's pretty bad.
I was, I right. I'm about it. It was like
about a three hour flight home. Sorry.
I know I'll be there as soon as I can.
So I get there and I pick her up from
the hospital and she's got the big thing
on and I get the story of, she was getting
in the shower and we have, you know,
big glass swinging shower
door and she fucking like,
she was like getting
in and like, you know,
holding onto like edge real quick as
the door slam shut on it and just locked
off the fucking whole like to the knuckle
basically. They put that shit
back on, fixed it up a little bit.
It looks pretty fucking good
now. But that was crazy.
Now you just reminded me of it with
the whole Ron arousing years or so.
It's amazing that they
don't break more often.
They're so gentle much it would
be over like if that part of my,
this finger like this is the
guitar on the fret hand like that.
If I lost that part of
that finger, um, I got,
it's going to take me four or five years
to learn how to play with just these,
at least my friend Paul was closing a
window and it shattered and cut his finger
and cut through the
tendons and his fingers,
like permanently curled and he had a bunch
of operations to try to straighten it
out, but then eventually just gave up.
They could never straighten it out.
It never gained like full
range of motion from a window.
Like it's so delicate. All this
stuff is so delicate and you know,
that's why it's great.
That's got flight on mine,
so ridiculous us a glass
door, not sharp really.
I went home and looked at it and like
it was pretty beveled on the edges,
but the weight of it just lopped
off the fucking thing or like crazy.
She was pretty gangster though. I
have to say she was pretty gangster.
What do you think of that scene or
putting his hand in that fucking pulling
thing actually posted. I
don't, I don't, I think she,
I don't think it's on her Instagram.
She posted the tip of her finger in
the plastic bag as she took it to the,
Oh my God. Oh, you're in God's
little dude. Chip ice in the bag.
Oh Jesus Christ. They couldn't reattach,
but they, it was like they, uh,
were able to like extend
it somehow and like,
and that luckily the dude out right there,
there's a dude who was an expert
at hand plastic surgery and wow.
Hooked her shit up. Like it looks like
relative, this looks pretty normal.
Something happens to your skin. Like if
your finger gets chopped off at the end,
there's a way to make it grow back,
right. Isn't there, am I making this up?
It seems like, I remember there was,
there's a way where if something happens
to your tip of your finger, oh yeah.
If you don't get the bulk and
it, yeah, I've heard that.
I think they said something like that,
but I get got hurt pink hot
piece of her bone just wow.
That's why I'm saying it's so shocking
at how it just locked it up clean like a,
it's like a angle like whip and wow.
You like that sound effect. Yeah. Whip.
I keep thinking that one day they're
going to come up with a artificial Luke
Skywalker type hands and that people
are gonna want them instead of regular
hands. That's what I'm worried about.
Wow.
If they came up with an arm, it would
sound like metal or metal. Unless you,
if you had the skin like simulation.
I can play guitar with that.
Maybe I'm talking about
self. I do some wild shit.
I'm talking about self healing.
Bulletproof spider silk,
hybrid skin like that. The
government's working on [inaudible].
They're working on that right now.
They're working on some sort of odd,
don't doubt it, man. I, I, I wanna
you want to hear a wild one? Alright,
I went on, you know, one night fucking
smoking. I went on a little youtube,
uh,
warm whole situation and somehow,
I don't even know if it's a
youtube video or someone else,
but I wound up on this
video that was like,
world's smartest kid thinks that
cern blew the world up in 2008.
All right. And I'm like, what the fuck?
So I go on this video and I'm watching
this video dude, and it's this young kid,
he's like 12 in a month, fuck is
talking, you know, half the, your,
you got to invest like 20 minutes into
this kid's talking about things that are
super smart and it's Kinda like
to show you he's super smart.
You know what I mean? This kid and his
dad is doing the recording I believe,
or a relative,
somebody very close to them and he goes
into this whole theory of how he thinks
when they collided the
electrons I believe at in the,
in the, in the supercollider sorry,
that they cause some crazy chain
reaction that blew up the universe.
But they also weighed,
they created an Adam that
weighed too much and he has,
oh the first 20 minutes is also
explaining infinite parallel universes.
So what the kid winds up with this,
this theory of like one Adam weighing
too much and way and is that being just
enough to shift our universe
into a parallel universe
yet this is it right here.
So this guy had, this kid had me
fucked up because after I watched this,
everything I saw for months was talking
about like it would be news guy on the,
on the news like I don't know what
universe I'm in anymore or ah,
Spiderman into the spider
verse. Like all these,
everything I saw for like four or five
months after watching this video was like
multi-verse shit like shit about multi
versus, and it's got me fucked up.
Joel, I hear you. I'm fucked up man.
Read this kid, look into it.
Says there, he claims it.
Cern destroyed the universe doing recent
experiments which has resulted in us
living in a nearby parallel
universe instead. Your welcome ETI.
There's a lot of people online.
This is an explanation for all the Mandela
effect finding goes into stuff about
the Mandela effect. How that, you know,
there's apparently a bunch
of people who think Mel,
Odette Mandela died in prison. And like
there's, you know, and as far as I know,
he was released, became president
in South America, you know,
and that's the universe. I
just personally, you know,
but it's crazy dude. What?
Cause it's not just this video,
it's like you watch it and that Youtube
Algorithm starts sending you down a
whole bunch of other, you know what I
mean? You start here and it's like, it's,
and then again,
everything that came out there was all
these shows I would see or movies or
news, things about Multa multi-verse all
of a sudden was everywhere around me.
It was fucking Nettie Dude. So I'm
fucked up about that shit right now.
If there was something, everything do,
if there was something that they could
do that might open up a door to a
parallel universe, you don't think
they would do stranger things you mean?
Yeah, I'd say that's because stranger
things, I mean, things are strange,
right? Stranger things. Bizarro world.
You know, what's the weirdest one is the,
the like the people that
dismiss climate change.
That is the weirdest one to
me because I'm like, what is,
I'm trying to figure out what's the
benefit of dismissing climate change other
than if you work for like the oil industry
or something just lost the glacier.
Yeah,
like they just posted a whole thing of
10 years or 80 like something in the 80s
a glacier picture of it and
just now, and it's gone.
But I'm not even saying
like blaming anybody for it.
I'm saying dismissing it
as an issue. I'm like,
let's pretend that people have
nothing to do with it. Let's just,
I wish people had nothing to do
with it because then we can go,
holy fuck, it's getting
hot. Like how hot is it?
Gonna get like we could
just figure it out.
Like if it was just occurred at
this point where it's two degrees,
the oceans are hotter than they've been
and she never had people do that where
they try to say like,
this is a natural cycle.
This is something some people
still say. Right. Okay.
Even if it was just a natural cycle,
I wish humans weren't in the equation
at all. So there was no argument.
I wish it would just be like, hey
guys, it's getting really hot.
What the fuck do we do? As if we
had no control over whatsoever.
Not saying that we shouldn't take steps
to fix it and we definitely should,
but I'm saying that if it was impossible
for people to have created it and it
was happening around us, maybe we
would be forced to do something.
Maybe we'd be forced to like go to
higher ground, get the fuck out of that.
The really hot spots, you know,
make your way towards Canada.
Like, I mean maybe that would w what
we would do if there was no other way,
but we know that at least part
of what the problem is is people,
at least part of the problem.
But so many people would start th th they
want to start arguments about that and
fight that. And to me it's so strange.
It's like what's the benefit of
arguing against that? It's happening.
I don't understand like it's
happening. You see it getting warmer.
You see the statistics. You see
everybody freaked out though.
The Amazon's on fire. If you seen
this. No, it's fucking horrifying.
Those photos from self harm, they're
just, and I believe it's purposeful.
I have heard that that is the,
that some people are being burned
away on purposes. What I'm, if I,
some of the things I've read or
understood, I won't swear their truth.
Cause again, that's one of the
things what you're saying is,
is you've got to question everything.
Now truth has been compromised man.
You know what I mean? No matter what side
of whatever you are on truth has been,
has been seriously compromised because
there's a counter opinion to everything
and if you're not adept enough to
really get involved and find factual
information, you can literally
counter any argument there is with,
with something. Oh I said, well I
read this while I read this. Okay,
well that doesn't mean either
one of those things are true.
Let's go find the truth.
You know what I mean?
That doesn't exist anymore because
people just want to Google that shit,
get on and move on with
their day, you know, and,
and it's laziness on our part and
a lot of people don't want them.
It's like fucking this thing
that everybody's posting
with the Goddamn fucking
Instagram. I don't give
you permission. Use Ebay.
I read a whole other thing
that says the average American,
I believe signs one or two legal
documents a day without reading them.
And just by logging
into shit on your phone,
Amazon or Instagram or whatever
you, every time you do that you,
you subscribe and, and, and, and
adhere to their terms and conditions.
And some you think a picture of a
copied and pasted Instagram thing over
something that was from Facebook fucking
12 years ago. It's, it's bananas,
bananas. People get roped
into things. You know,
one person see smart people posting
in the sand. Better safe than sorry.
Like I've seen that too. What argument
is that? They don't know how to Internet.
They don't know how to Internet.
I'm just saying even if just like
you suspect it's wrong, but you know,
fuck it anyways. It's like, wait, wait.
That's, if you suspect it's wrong,
take the extra time or
just don't do it at all.
Like what do you mean? I'm just
using that as an example of how,
why we're with the state of
things are as they are. Yeah.
It's a sneaky little loophole. That's a
sneaky little thing that happens to you.
You have to, everybody's posting something
stupid. Did you send it to me? Oh,
Everlast sent it to me. It must be legit.
Just post it. You know what I mean?
How many times have you done
that? I've done that all the time.
I was some clown in it and then
immediately after it Dana came up.
It was him posting the exec they name
with the whole like better safe than sorry
thing. Christ, you know
they gone mad. Oh dude,
they got everybody though. They got
that fucking grade Perry guy. Everybody.
Everybody isn't big Perry's
job like fucking protect
the nukes or something like
governor or something posted
to Rick. What did Rick Perry,
they said Rick Perry pub, but, but he
has a specific job in a government.
It's like the energy, the energy
secretary. He's like in control. The News,
right? Is that what it is? Energy
Secretary? Yeah, you are. I don't know.
Whatever the fuck he is. He's
got a big job and he fell for it.
Oh, it's bizarro world when bizarro
world. Maybe that fucking kid is right.
I'm telling you, dude, you're
Yo, you're going to be calling
me in a couple nights like, fuck you
dude. Why did you even tell me about that?
I've really about, I've bounced the
idea of multiple universes many times.
We all have, but this kid watch
it. Just you're going to invest it,
give it 20 minutes or 1518 minutes,
whatever it is, and then you'll be like,
oh wow. It's, it's not that. It's
Oh fact. It's, but it's like, wow,
that's super possible. It's super, super
possible. The way he breaks it down.
What about this? What if every time
you went to sleep and you woke up,
you passed into a nearby,
very similar universe,
but not quite the same.
And depending upon your choices
and how you live your life,
it's how you wake up and what new
one you pop into and the other side.
And everyone's just a
little bit different.
The whole world changes just a little
bit. Each time you make a decision,
one way or another, everything
changes. When you wake up,
you think the world is static because
it is when you're awake and you have no
fucking idea what's happening while
you're asleep. And when you wake up again,
you have this foggy recollection of the
past and that's what you're going by.
You're going by every morning, waking up
with a foggy recollection of the past.
That's what you're doing and you're,
you're assuming that nothing's
changed and everything static.
And while you were asleep for eight
hours, nothing weird happened.
You know the fuck you're talking about.
You have no idea. You're dreaming.
You're crazy fantasies.
It shit weird stuff has happened
and you're fucking mermaids.
You're flying through the air on a, uh,
on a helicopter, you know, you don't,
you weird things happen when you're
dreaming. What is all that about?
We don't even know. We have no idea what
that is. That soup of possibilities.
It's fucking swirling around in between
your ears while you're snoring up a
storm and then boom, you wake up.
Are you sure those memories are real?
Are you sure that this is in a whole
completely new university you're living in
today or simulation or simulation?
There was some ice simulations
out on that one right there.
There was some fucking,
another genius super wizard kid
who was talking about that, that,
that something about
simulations. I forget what,
I was high at the house with mom, with
the guy who runs my studio divine and,
and, and, and we were just fucking
laughing, talking shit one day hire like,
like what if like I may have heard
this could have been on your show,
I could have read this. So I'm not
claiming like ownership of the thought,
but it was like, what if like we
just come from a universe like this.
So perfect and shit and it's boring as
fuck and we just plug in to have all
these fucked up like weird problems.
And that's why everything's getting
fucking weird or in crazier because like
that's kind of why we're here.
That's part of the ride, you know?
That could be it.
It could be the only way you
appreciate love is to no hate.
They'll really appreciate it.
And it could be the only way we would
appreciate all the good that we have is to
balance it out with all
the bad that we have.
And when they start to overwhelm
each other one way or the other,
there's an imbalance that takes place
and leads to all of our fucking problems
as a society.
And when you think about how long you're
going to be alive and what it is that
you're doing here and why you're doing it,
you know all those weird questions and
answers that go on inside your head.
It's all you're distributing energy,
right? You're trying to figure out,
am I distributing my energy right? My, uh,
am I living my life in a way that is
like the best I can do with what I've got
right now. That's it.
All these mind fucks. That's
all you gotta do though.
I mean as even no matter
what we're saying,
if you woke up every day and
that was your objective. Yeah.
You couldn't really go or do
much wrong. No, no you can't.
And what if every day when you did that
woke up in the nearby universe that was
just to live a bit different because
of what you thought and dead dude,
that's like, you know, that's
a movie magic type Shit.
Everlast some movie magic type Shit.
I just was like, I tried to be a
not such a glutton. There we go.
Salute Silo DJ Melody over there. I
just wanted to cheers. How bout cheers.
Let's go. American guys
sent pictures. Cheers. GJ
Yeah, you gotta you gotta
DJ Bro. The only guy ever.
I didn't see the shooting. I
believe besides myself as honey,
honey man. No. [inaudible] I
think they're the only one.
We're the ones that have done music
on the shore. Not totally true.
Is that true? You might be right.
You were definitely the first.
And then Gary Clark brought
his guitar, but we just chill.
I'm a huge fan of that. I think will
brought his guitar the first time.
He might not even brought his guitar first
time. Joe Simpson Sturgeon. Yeah. No,
I hung out with him once.
[inaudible] sneaker shop on Melrose.
They have a new song that
he just released. His new
album is fucking incredible.
I got a chance to listen to it in advance
before it's released and they just
released something on youtube.
It's like this Japanese
Anamae with a, what is the,
what's the name of the actual video
so people could find it on day two,
sing along, sing along.
It's fucking amazing song.
But the video was coolest shit
man. It's all this Japanese anime.
So he did all of this, uh,
the did like all these
crazy animations. He's,
that's like a film that takes place
while the album plays. Oh Shit. Yeah.
So it's all coordinated
to the songs. I mean,
he's been working on this shit for ever.
He's been flying back and
forth to Japan and La.
I mean this is a labor of love.
No, it's like to style. Incredible.
I met him, like I said, my buddy owns
a sneaker shop on mill road and he was,
I guess a bit of a sneakerhead himself.
Oh really? Politics. Sturdy Shit.
He's one of my favorite people.
I like the stuff to the music that
the country kind of outlawish like,
but like big band dish. Yeah. You
know what I love about that guy?
He didn't even try to go for it as a
professional musician until he was like 36
his wife talked him into it.
His wife was like, you know,
you don't suck. That's like
what? She said, that's, that's
great. That's high praise.
And she's like, you're fucking
good. And he's, and he went for it
for somebody who wakes up with Aaron,
goes to bed with you so you don't suck.
I mean, that's what I praise, you know.
But he had like crazy jobs, like
railroad worker, shit like that.
Like did a bunch of like regular jobs
and just was writing music and singing
music. And then she convinced
him to go for it. Yeah.
He's an unusual character,
man. This stuff, this,
all this new stuff is different.
I, it's like he used to be,
you would think of him as
country, like you can even,
you don't even know what to say now
with his new stuff is not country.
It's wild though. It's really good.
Check it out. Yeah. It's like it's a,
this kind of hybrid rock thing he's doing,
but it's pretty fucking bad ass.
This is Waylon.
Waylon had sex with Queens of the
Stone Age while the black keys watched
first comment on the video. Who
said that? Who's named that guy?
Top comment shall be Riley.
Shelby. Riley, congrats. Congrats. You
won. You won the Internet for the day.
That is exactly what it sounds like. It's
really good stuff. He's a sing along.
You said that was good. Yeah. I'm
checking out now. It's doing weird shit.
That's the only thing that's doing it,
man. It's, you know, and I, you know,
weird shit in the sense of like, Yo shit
that excites you since you said like,
you know, you know, don't worry. I'm not,
I've never tried to make the
same thing twice, you know,
cause it's like I want to be
excited. I want to be scared to fail.
You know what I mean? Yeah. I want
to, I want to be like, you know,
oh that didn't work next
time. Yeah. Well you,
you've always switched shit up.
That's one of the more interesting
things about you. It's like when,
when you were doing what it's like and
when you switched up to like Whitey Ford
sings the blues, everybody was like, Whoa,
what is this? Is this is, this is the
jump around. God is the house of pain guy.
But it it, it was a,
it felt so easy to digest for most people
because this is before I knew you and
I was like, it's so easy
because it's so authentic.
I gets very obvious that this was the
kind of music that you were writing was
like music that like came from your
feelings and your soul. It was like, wow,
this is real shit. And
I was 2020 years ago,
what it's like was a classic.
That was a classic. That was
one of those songs was like,
that's a heartfelt song.
That's how soul filled song,
you know, that's like a universal
song. Yeah. I went to, uh,
New York.
I left house of pain and went to New
York with a buddy of mine and was kind of
sleeping on his couch
and he had a guitar there.
I started streaming it one night and
singing these little words and he came
Barston out at his room in the
back like, what the fuck is that?
And kind of was like, we're recording.
That's why we were making a rap record.
I was like there to like just kind of
further the rap career and nobody really
knew I played guitar and stuff like that
a little bit. So, but it was his, his,
his encouragement. It definitely
came back. Like when he was like,
I think he was with it broad back there
and he just heard the song and jumped
out like, wow, what the fuck
is that? You know what I mean?
And so the next day he,
they basically forced me to record
it so I had to finish. Right.
I had wrote it like that night I
had, I think I had the first part,
the whole liquor store guy
at the liquor store thing,
but I didn't really have anything else.
But he heard that part and was like, Yo,
we need to finish that. When you get
those ideas, when they come to you,
what does that feel
like? Does it feel like,
like a gift comes out of the universe?
The mouth, the really good ones? Yeah.
You know what I mean? I
mean, what blows my mind,
and I'm gonna flip it on you
real quick, is, is the, the,
the comic art arc of you get to work this
thing out for a whole long time and if
you're really successful
on your level type thing,
then you shoot a special and
that joke kind of goes away.
You can't, you know, really
get to tell that anymore.
And that blows my mind because like my
whole thing is like work this thing out
and build this thing that I can go out
and play every night for the rest of my
life. So like you're, you
know what I mean? Like,
so all the Kudos being thrown back and
forth when I look at you or any amazing
comedian that just turns it around and
every year or two years is belting out
these fucking funny ass specials and then
like you can't do that anymore. Like,
you know,
unless you're Andrew dice clay with the
little fucking Hickory dickory dock,
you know, and you got the little
later. You don't only guy ever that.
You want to hear the old stuff over
and over and over again like Oh,
I don't know. See a whole set of
just rhymes or even like, I'm like,
and now there's like,
you've familiar with this with
little Duvall comedian like you know,
and hit the whole singing. Like,
I mean he's like turning it into,
he's flipping this whole script on what
comedy and music and entertainment is
right now. He's kind of doing some
really fucking interesting shit.
Also got a bunch of crazy
shit going on. His Instagram.
Is Instagram hilarious too.
He's got something I need them.
Favorite follows him. He started like,
he starts cultural
phenomenon. US. Yes. Here,
you know like he set shit off.
Like I've watched him say some shit on
his Instagram and will it into existence
and it becomes like a trend or a
[inaudible]. The songs he's written,
it's just like, it's amazing. It's like
really like, no, it's a, it's a really,
it's one of my favorite follows,
honestly. Yeah. He's something special.
Andrew Schultz really made me take
a, I'm an, I, I knew about that song.
Smile Bitch actually found out about that
song because style bender style bender
would come out to with smile
bitch. And he came out to fight when
they talked about it, he goes, ah,
I love bill Duvall. I'm like, Oh,
let me check out little Duvall.
And I was like, God damn, this guy's
good. And then Andrew Schultz says, Yo,
he's a comedian. And he goes,
he's one of the most insightful
and brilliant people I've ever met.
And just like, almost like a naturally
curious guy. Get him on. Yeah, always.
We're working on it. Yeah. We're going
to make it happen. But Schultz is,
it's going to be, Schultz is a wizard.
Schultz tells me that someone's good,
I'll buy it. Yeah. And it's like,
and he was early Internet like dude,
like he's been working these like Internet
angles kind of lay you got in really
early, saw some he liked and he's
got his own thing going on with the,
he's got his own thing going on with
that whole city boys country boys thing.
But that's all in relation to the
song. I know, I know, I know, I know.
But it's hilarious how people like
each other. It's like a daily thing.
You don't follow him. Go. Yeah go go.
He's one of the best falls little Duvall.
Just shoot me some tickets
to your next show in La.
I'm a huge fan that said you'd go to
however millions on this show followed
little new wall cause he's
hilarious and funny and yes.
Follow him to make sure that he's
not really shadow band anymore.
That shit's crazy. I got a friend
who going through that right now.
Like we're like they just disappear. I
felt like shit when you search for him,
[inaudible] is up there
now they're ghosting you.
I feel like it's always how you
can find them. Okay, good. Yeah,
they are telling you, man, you couldn't
find them for awhile. There you go,
Andrew. It was tricky.
It was very tricky. Very
tricky back in the day.
Yeah. Awesome.
Lil Duvall. So what do you want
to do today, man? You gotta DJ?
I brought a little, you know, we got
a few things to do we could do for,
you know, I brought a little, you know,
I've come here with just a guitar with
a keyboard player that I was like,
I'm going to bring my man from the
world famous beat junkies. DJ Melody.
Oh here. Oh, I liked it. They got it.
They got their own university, uh,
beat junkies. Institute of
Technology. Sound, sound,
beat junkies. Institute of Sound
in Glendale, California. Oh,
DJ Melody. Shout out to Baboo Jay rock
all the home. Shout out to everybody.
Yeah, we do. But yeah, we got
some things you want. You want,
who wants to get into something?
Let's get into something. Let's do it.
I'm gonna move over here real
quick, ladies and gentlemen.
I think it's only you and honey,
honey. I really do. I think so. Right?
Okay. I actually like that.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
yeah. All right. DJ Melody in that House.
Yeah. Joe Rogan experience
Everlast
[inaudible]
brand new sneakers in a bag.
Gold J K and we don't fail. No pain.
No window there. But
where I go, people don't,
may we got no money and bang
and nail to you mean to say no.
I don't feel bad at bowling.
A car was Danny live radical fanatic.
Jump out the bands with my
semiautomatics and rob. All my friends,
lack of fucking drug addict
and Terry
youngsters ask everywhere
around the whole time. Yes.
Pharma up drama Thomas
and calm. I found my
[inaudible] shit and my mental
condition map that come to fruition.
I'm all natural.
[inaudible] God was never
bowling. Tell your vision.
Grandville sneakers
and we'd
[inaudible] name. We got the money and
it was
called the days they give us
all the things they found us.
Instagram [inaudible] the devil
child
go. People know
[inaudible]
j which is good. Okay.
And we don't want to be [inaudible]
no way down. Come [inaudible]
[inaudible]
woo. That was great. I usually like it.
It's a new one. Yeah, just
east. Um, yeah, it is.
You know what happened
was right. We didn't,
even when I came in last time we did,
I think we agreed to just
fucking not talk about
our Sushi Shit. Like we were both like
kind of a little traumatized. That's me.
Right. And um, cause what happened
was I put this record out last,
what do I think? October, right.
Hit the road and you know,
maybe two weeks in and get a
picture of my house on fire.
I had to fly home. So
yeah, this records out.
But we're right now in the cloud where
right now I just shot a video for the,
for a new song and where we releasing,
cause I own everything. It's my label.
We're just going to rerelease you
know, O g Everlast on all the whatever,
whatever's, you know,
formats you could find me.
Do you feel like when you get through
something like a fire with your family
that like for some inexplicable reason
you feel like a little bit closer?
Oh yeah. Cause, I mean,
my wife and children were in the house
when it was caught fire, you know,
I mean, so yeah, I'm not
literally, here's how it went down.
Let's tell the story, right? Uh,
basically I said I was in New York.
I get a call from the wife, the
fire's right across the hill,
like I live literally like Simi
Valley, then the mountains, Bang.
I'm kind of the first line right there
once you come over those mountains. Um,
so I get a picture like from her,
like the across the street
from either of the hills,
just like it looks like hell
landscape. You know what I mean?
As fucking just on fire.
And I'm so they're packing up and they're
getting ready to get out and there's a
fire truck in the
neighborhood. Thank goodness.
And as my wife's putting the
final like stuff in the car,
like the kids are running, they're
just putting all the dogs and you know,
whatever the net, the medicines
and stuff we need for Layla.
And she turns around and sees
like on the corner of the garage,
like an orange kind of glow. And the
thing about this is like, you know,
people think the fire comes in his
street and then Johnson Burns all these
houses. That's not what happens.
If you ever noticed in the middle,
if you're watching the news shit,
it's like one random house in the
neighborhood bar is trees as having a tree
right on your house,
just touching your house.
Well I happened to have a tree right
there that was touching the corner of my
garage. The tree went up,
that thing caught garage went
about a third of the house went,
you know what I mean? Um, you know
where everybody was out already.
My wife was able to, the only reason a
third of the house and whole like my wife
saved our whole block honestly
because there's trees between every,
all of our houses like
for privacy, you know,
cause everybody has a pool
and everybody wants, you know,
nobody wants to be in two
story houses, all that shit.
So everyone just has these big, huge,
like those just spiny looking trees,
you know what I mean? Like go head cover,
turning to a wall basically. Right.
All the whole, the whole
block would have went up,
has she not been there and
had the wherewithal to run
down a block and get the
firemen that had just drove by and say
come back and fucking put this out.
She actually ran, she ran down the
block and got it done. She's a gangster.
She's a gangster out here was so it's
so hard for people to understand what it
was late. It was frightening.
It was like a war.
It was phrased like we were
at war with a natural force.
It was very strange man is that
everybody was holed up together. Um,
me and my family, we get a hotel in
town with a bunch of our friends.
We were texting, we were texting back
and forth and Tommy and his wife,
Thomas Gert and his wife,
they came over to and we were all in the
same place and it was like we were all
like refugees for like a
small, tiny period of time.
It makes you realize how fortunate we
really are to be here in this, you know,
this place like where we're at
right now where we can just,
we don't have to deal with most of the
bullshit that people are dealing with all
over the world. Man. You know, we just
one day of fire, one week of fire,
whatever it was that freaked everybody
out and scare the shit and a lot of
people lost their lives or houses rather.
A lot of people also lives in northern
California. Right. I know that was,
that's why it's like even worse than
down. Couldn't even it was, yeah.
You couldn't even like really get a
perspective like for your own shit.
Cause the minute you
wanted to like do that,
you saw an entire town
flattened in like an hour.
They lost him on the highway and people
were trying to get out on the highway
and they get caught in their cars and
they caught fire. Man, it's horrible.
And there's um, you know,
for the people that survived,
like for us, it sounds ridiculous
to call yourself a survivor.
It's not like it was a war,
but it's something that
you really understand when
you get through that you're
like, wow, like we are barely in
control of our own environment. Barely.
And all it takes is one good strong wind.
One good fucking hot day on one good
Gusta fire and next thing you know
everything's on fire. I mean
that was nuts. The kids,
the kids are still
dealing with it. You know,
I'm trying to explain that thing to the
kids of like that universal unsurity
like there's just not really, honey,
I'm going to keep you safe as I can,
but if you really want the absolute truth,
I can only tell you that some
shit happens. And you know,
it was actually another big fire
somewhere. Oh is oddly enough,
when Notre Dame caught fire, it was
all in the news and my daughter,
my oldest was like, oh that caught
fire. You know, cause she always me,
I proposed my wife in, in Paris. So
like we talk about Paris a lot so she,
you know, looks forward to
all that she wanted to see.
She was really interested in Notre
Dame when thing burnt. But then,
but something about that burning and
when it did and she saw it, she was like,
oh it can happen anywhere. And
it Kinda, and it kind of dawned
on her like, okay, it's
not just there that plea.
Cause for a long time I couldn't
even drive by the house with her,
like to go check on it or something.
But if she was in the
car and my wife either,
cause she just didn't want
to be over there. Right.
And then after that it kinda changed and
she kind of realized like, well it's,
I guess it's Kinda can happen anywhere
you have it can happen to note it.
Which was a crazy thing to witness
happen in a human like person,
like come to that
understanding of like, wow,
shit's just not guaranteed.
Like in a weird way, you know,
but isn't there kind of a,
there's a magic of that. Yeah.
If you can get through, if you serve,
if you're one of the
survivors is a magic in that,
that doesn't exist without the possibility
of that. I have people asking me,
what are you going to do? And I'm
like, what do you mean? They're like,
you're going to build a house in
the same spot. I'm like fucking God.
Damn right. You know
what mean? Absolutely.
I don't live in like some
crazy bizarro like place.
I'm going to build my
house right where I was.
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do with the
House on top of a hill that's put the
sprinklers on your house like
that. People have the sprinklers.
There was a neighbor there was catched
that whole neighborhoods burned down and
then the one house I had the
sprinklers, that couch was pristine.
The problem with that is you
do get survivor syndrome.
You feel you feel weird.
You see get survivor guilt of the first
three houses in front of me right in
front of my house.
You know what three houses gone
that I could understand that if, if,
if you were like the guy who kind of
futuristically predicted a fire and put
that on and where but after now it's
like, Yo, if you didn't put shit on that,
everybody knows about that shit. Now,
so put this shit in
your house or you know,
if you're going to live in one of these
areas, we're basically in California,
they're telling us now this might
be a new norm, you know what I mean?
These kind of fires, you know,
so cause there hadn't been one
in the area, you know the air,
those areas I go go red hills and Simi
Valley and there hadn't been one for
many, many, many, like a couple decades.
I believe climate change is not
real. No, it's fake. It's fake news.
It's something that something's clearly
happening. Right. This is not normal.
Right. If you had to guess my 36 years,
so it seems like there's
had been an adjustment.
I've been the same Irish,
white motherfucker all my life and I
didn't burn like this when I was young.
When did you move to la? Oh, I've
been hearing most of my life.
Like I was born in New York and
whatever and probably did a, a um,
kindergarten part of first grade
out there. And then for the,
like my dad was a construction
dude, like during the 70s,
boom of like Simi Valley and
all that shit and being built.
He came out during that era, nobody
talked about crazy fires back then.
Did they? They didn't, not really
the first I got evacuated for the first
time while we were filming fear factor.
And I remember I was driving home
and it started, there was a fire,
it seemed like it was a little bit out
of control but like wow this is crazy and
I'm driving to work and then we filmed
the day and then as we're driving home
people are letting us know, hey man
this is bad. This has gotten really bad.
And uh, as we were driving
home, a guy got hit a car
and he got killed and uh,
I didn't see his body but I saw a shoe
and really like passing by or like all
these people were freaking out because
the guy apparently just tried to run into
the highway and some guy hit him
cause he was panicking cause he was,
there was a bunch of shit
going on. There was fire,
I don't know if he was panicking,
but something happened.
The guy got hit by a car, so has
this ominous feeling of, whoa,
somebody just died and we're driving down
this highway and the whole right side
is on fire. I mean the whole right
side of the highway for an hour,
like a lord of the rings
movie more door dude was like,
flakes of ash are falling from
the sky like a, like a light snow.
It's fucking strange.
You just waiting for demons to come riding
on fucking horses over the top of the
hills. It's that bad. And
uh, by the time I got back,
we had to evacuate from our community
and we'd just get the fuck out of dodge.
That was the first time that had
ever happened ever for me. Uh,
living out here since 94 and
that was in like 2000, two,
three, something like that. And
then it's happened twice since then.
It's a creepy feeling, man.
It's creepy. It's like,
you know that no one can do
anything if everything goes wrong.
If everything goes wrong and the wind
gets too strong. And it gets too wide.
He goes left and it goes
right and everything starts
swirling around and ashes
fly through the air and they
land on other people's houses.
Like you gotta get the fuck out of there,
just get out of there as a storm of fire.
Well, but it's like, all
right, so the, I get a picture,
the last thing before I get on a plane
is a picture of my garage engulfed in
flames. Right. So I get on this plane,
I gotta take like three planes cause it's
like last minute booking and it's all
coach. I'm pissed. You know what I
mean? I'm like, I'm like, I'm not,
I'm just like tucked in corners
on the walls. Like everything.
I just fly like of to
Dallas than to Vegas.
And just to get there the quickest
and it was like three flights.
So I get there. I think the
whole way there, I'm like,
my house is burned to the ground.
You know what I mean? That's, I've,
I'm accepted. I'm dealing
with those whatever,
five stages of grief and like I'm getting
to acceptance and then I get home and
I a not even at home. I had my wife
and kids were at my studio and like,
you know, that's where we're,
we're laid up from, you know,
just trying to figure out
what the fuck's going on.
I can't get to the house because the
whole one-on-one shut down that way I have
to literally drive up to paying a hit
the one 18 take that out all the way out
to like the 20 whatever it is, the three
23 or 27 I don't know. It's one of the,
I know it's the 23 it's like out there
and you come back down and come around
the other way. And I was able to get
to the house, I got to the house,
I got in my house, literally had
20 fucking cop cars roll in. Like,
cause looting was fucking out of
control dude. And they're like,
oh Gora and Calabasas areas park. It
was oak park. Yeah. Well that's, that's,
I don't, I think that is a Gora and,
and the same thing. Yeah. But yeah,
the whole over there was fucking like
off the chain with fucking looting.
So like I had monk pull up on me.
I literally knew like I sh I brought
my lease and my father and I, my, my,
my mortgage and my electric bill
and I brought my, I, you know,
I had all my shit so
they doesn't miles and I,
and they were cool but it was like I
pulled up and like saw most of the house
standing and like broke down cause I'm a,
I'm a big art collector and August.
So I was like, I had already liked,
just assumed it was all gone, you
know. And you know, it was crazy.
It was a crazy experience
to like pull up in Nice,
see like two thirds of it
there and you're like, oh wow.
Like maybe there's salvage like in the
salvage shit. Like they was like, oh,
crazy experience man.
I'm grateful that my family is safe
and all that and all the rest of it is
replaceable stuff. But I got
extremely lucky. Yeah, no the most,
I mean it's like such a cliche thing to
say that your health and your happiness
and your family is the most
important thing. You know,
that everybody knows that we are even
us. Fucking psychopath knows that.
But to feel it,
to feel it like in the presence of a
natural fury like fires, like wildfires.
It's humbling and in the strangest of
ways it makes you love each other more,
makes you nicer to people.
All my refugee friends
in her, when we're at the
hotel that night, you know,
the refugees from the fire,
we're all like closer.
We're like happy for sure. You
know, in a weird way, you know,
we're having drinks together, we're
toasting, we're hugging, you know,
we're in a hotel hiding from a
natural fury and you realize like,
oh, OK we, we, we have, we have,
we get soft when we hit a soft spot.
And that's not necessarily
good for anybody.
And occasionally these are horrific things
that happen are good for us overall.
Cause they let us appreciate like there's
consequences to his consequences to
live in here.
There's consequences to everything
being so hot and dry and never fucking
raining. And the fact that it may or
may not be getting a little [inaudible],
a little warmer, maybe no, maybe
who gives a fuck if people have
do with it, who cares? Let's
pretend that's not even a factor.
Something's happening.
Something's happened.
And we got firestorms like every
few years. The God damn firestorm,
you know,
craziness man. Well, we
survived your brother. Yeah.
This salon HSA Salon, there's
only so much you can think about.
Like you, uh, you know,
you haven't gone through that man.
If you written shit that has a,
like the, the touch of that honor.
Um, like in, in like a,
a very kind of creative state like
state at the moment. Like, so we're,
I don't what's there's, there's,
I'm sure there's elements of it and what
I'm like starting to play with right
now. Do you sit down and write like on a
piece of paper or do you write why you,
yeah. For me, writing is
a visual process. Visual,
yes. And I can't, if I write it
down, it becomes two dimensional.
And I've never, I've,
I've written lyrics that I thought were
genius and actually committed them to
paper and saw them and they beat and they,
it's like they dissolve from this
three dimensional beauty to like, oh,
it's two dimensional garbage.
It's fucking bizarre.
I know it's not always like reasonable,
but it's my process at this point.
How's it visual? It's if you really listen
to my songs, they're like photograph.
Like it's like flipping through
a photographic album almost.
If you really listened to like what
I'm doing, that's like very visual.
I see the pictures, I equate it to like,
did you ever watch the show Oz? Sure.
I remember the poet guy who, who,
who was illiterate but he drew pictures
and that's how he recited his poems from
pictures. It's similar. It's like, but
it's kind of reverse. It's in my brain.
It's, it's there.
So you're seeing your visual in terms of
like the stories that you're painting,
like the guy outside the liquor store
or the imagery? Yes. Or like, you know,
a song like black Jesus where it's like
just kind of cultural like fucking pop
culture reference after reference leading
down a path of just like a stream of
consciousness, pop culture
references, you know what I mean?
I'll go on tangents, you know what I mean?
But it'll be all within an energy in the
inside the brain, you know what I mean?
Like once I commit them, I
even like after the fact,
like when you turn in like music to like
entities that have shows or whatever,
they want to know the lyrics so they
can know if they should put it on air or
this, you know, it depends on
whatever, if it's public now.
But even when it comes
to that, I have to have,
I have to like recite it to somebody
and have them type it, I can't, it'll,
it'll just kind of taint it to me. Wow.
See it written down in my hand, you
know what I mean? And in another hand,
it doesn't bother me, but like for
me to come to do it, it, it, it,
it like it breaks a barrier of
some sort and then everything.
Vaporizes so do you, uh,
how do you capture the various beats?
Do you record it as you're
coming up with it? There's a,
there's a few different ways of
Hams from me. Like, you know,
if I'm doing like a hip hop ish
or hip pure hip hop project, I'll,
there'll be a beat involved
always first. You know,
I mean there'll be somebody who
have a track and we'll be like, oh,
that's the track we're going to commit
to this and we'll write lyrics to it and
it'll be just kinda like I said, I'll,
I'll drive around a lot with rap stuff
and just let it bump and see what word
starts popping up. I like word
play and pouncing word play,
but I'd know it can't just be
worth played for the sake of it.
It has to like tie into
some sort of like idea. Um,
when it comes to a song,
it's usually I string together
some simple chord progression and,
and start and, and see and, and if I,
once I've see something I really
like, it'll just, like I said,
pictures will start coming up and you
kinda just try to describe the picture a
little bit. And sometimes you,
you come across poetry when you're
describing the picture and you'd be like,
that's good. Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of like not
that's not good and that's not good.
There's a lot of that.
It seems like a mere process to stand
up comedy. It's a mirror process,
except I get to hold onto mine. Even
if they record it and make a special,
I still can play mine. And that's,
that's what I was with. I, man,
comedians are just, that's a little bit,
it's a different commitment because like
you're, you're bringing, you're like,
it's almost like a chow you're raising
that you have to watch the life of it
finish in a weird way. I'm not, you
know what I mean? We both have children.
That's extreme, but I know what
you're saying, but like you're,
you're taking this idea from kind
of garbage idea that, you know,
there's a premise there and then like
over a fucking series of fucking shells or
nights or fucking maybe months.
You, you find it, you know,
with different audiences and then you got
it and yet you get to rocket for maybe
six months good.
And all these places and then you go
and record it and make that special.
If you're lucky enough to
be on that level, you know,
it's almost like I almost
envy the [inaudible].
I wonder if you guys ever
envy the comic who quite,
it doesn't quite have that yet. So
he can like he has this, you know,
bevy of material that he hasn't had
to trash yet. You know what I mean?
As they talk to the
Roy would about that. It was
just on right before you hit.
That's one of the things that he said
that you shouldn't do TV for like 10
years. Like don't do,
it's like catalog man.
It'll come up with that.
I'll get it like the first time you do
anything that people get to see like be
hardened, like be Polished
Samurai of stand up, you know?
But I disagree. I say let them see
everything. Let them see all the bullshit,
all this stuff that sucks.
All the terrible jokes.
Who Cares? Just keep going.
Especially if the progressions there.
Then it's like, Oh, you see what?
Just keep going and it's
good for everybody to see.
People don't want to think you just
like someone who just figured it out
instantly. No, it's good to see these
sucked. It's good for everybody.
It might be bad for your
ego, but it's good for you.
When your ego get takes a hit.
It's always good. It's always good.
It puts everything in
perspective. You know?
Don't you think like as an artist too,
like the thing that gets in your way
more than anything, it's your ego, right?
The thing that gets in the
way more than anything,
it's for sure the way you view
yourself. You want people to view you.
I wouldn't produce my own records until
like maybe two albums ago because I felt
like if I'd made it through an album
without being like seriously challenged,
I didn't make the best record I could.
And then just being involved with a
bunch of really seriously good producers,
I learned to challenge myself and,
and even the records
I've produced for myself,
there's other guys involved
producing with me that are,
that I know are going to be the ones,
if that's something, hey that sucked.
But you know what I mean? You're going
eat dad guy around the, or even a
guy just to challenge you how
committed you are to certain ideas,
you know what I mean?
How much time do you spend going over?
Like when you have a song and you're
like, I think, I think this song is solid.
Do you, do you it outside
of singing the song?
Do you ever go over the song and ponder
like what you're saying or how you're
saying it? Like, how do you,
because your stuff is so,
it's so interesting
because you're, you're,
you're telling these stories of your
experiences in these songs and in a lot of
them and you're also having fun
and you're also talking shit,
you're having a good time with them
as well. But when you decide, okay,
this one is going to be recorded like
this, how do you make that conclusion?
For me, it's, uh, again,
if there's not like,
cause I can also, even if I'm not
doing necessarily a straight rap song,
there's times when I get atrack from a
producer that I just love the track and
I'll build something around
that. Other than that,
it'll again start with a
guitar and I'll either,
um, create a, a very, uh,
rudimentary drum beat and lay down the
guitar and maybe a vocal and I have a
very unique voice. You know,
it's not like it's there between the
guitar and the voice tone start appearing
that like resemble
other instruments to me.
Like it almost starts telling you what
to do. Oh, that's not, that sounds,
I could hear her Rhodes in there or I,
you know, the baseline, I should do that.
You know, you can hear that.
And the guys I surround myself with are
beasts that hear the same, you know,
they know, oh yeah, this, I hear
that, let's do it. You know,
you can start a song, we'll tell
you what to do with it. You know,
if you really listened to it. I
believe that. Cause I, I kinda, uh,
you know, one of the things
Santana told me, you know,
that I always held onto was
like, you know, because,
and I've experienced this once or twice
where I've written very similar songs to
friends of mine or people I know that
was like, Whoa, I maybe not sounding,
but like the idea of wow,
I wrote something that was
exactly. And he said like,
you know,
we're all just saying antenna that are
like catching energies and shit and like
bringing them in and we're, you know,
bringing Megan some out of that energies.
And sometimes people catch
that same energy and similar
things happen, you know?
And so I always look at a dad. I,
I look at my ideas like this also
because I don't write them down.
I equate it to like my children like this.
Like my ideas are like little
animals that are wild and I,
I see them and I think they're
amazing and I want to, and so I, I,
I'll play a song until I know it so well.
It has to stick around if I train it to
stay and if it stays the next morning,
that's, this kind of answers your
question. The next day. If I arrive,
I'm on to some and I write a
song, I'll sing it 200 times.
If I get it close to done
and then I'll go to bed.
And then if it's there in the
morning in the, in the same,
I'm recording. If it's gone, I didn't,
it wasn't mine and has happened
a lot too. Brave move. Yeah.
I have the opposite cowards
approach. If I get an idea,
I'll run away from everybody, my, my
fingers in my ears and write it down,
you know, hear what I said. I'll sing
it 200 times. You know what I mean?
So if I've done it 200 times
and I don't wake up and know it,
it's fucking trash. I write everything.
It's not supposed to happen.
I have the total opposite approach
in terms of writing comedy. I write,
how many specials have
you made in your life?
I never counted rough guess.
It's like eight or nine.
Alright. That's how many albums
I've done in almost 30 years. Yeah.
You know what I mean? So it's like
I'm not turning them out like that.
I thought, you know, and I
don't, again, because of that,
there's not like this crazy archive of
garbage that's going to be released when
I'm dead. It's not gonna happen. It's
not gonna happen. It's not gonna happen.
Cause I even saw as I started to record,
if I get halfway through it and I'm
like not even satisfied with it,
it gets erased. You
know what I mean? There,
there's a few things
out there that, that I,
that I probably wouldn't have released,
but they're not there like from house
of pain days and they're not bad.
I've just like, they weren't
for, they didn't have a purpose.
I think it's good for people to
see bad shit from great artists.
I do. I think it's good. It's good. It's
good for everybody. I have no problem.
I mean, I'm the guy that fuck,
I'll fuck up live and talk about it for
five minutes of the show and be like,
Yo, at least you know it's not on
fucking tape. Right. And I'll be like,
that's real shit. You know, and
I'll, I'll, you know, I'm with that.
I'm just like, it's my process. It's
like, just the way I do, like again, also,
I think it has to do with,
I had some really hard core producers
like DJ Muggs and my man, Dante Ross,
these were dudes that would be like,
that fucking was garbage do it again.
It's for so long that that's, I'm a re,
the first time now is going to
be decent. You know what I mean?
So it's like I gotta push myself
to, for it to be better than decent.
Otherwise I just clip it. Yeah. Well,
that's the only way you could be as
productive as you are. Like you've a,
you have a well oiled approach, you know,
but I don't put out a lot of music,
but when I know for a fact when you put
something out, you're happy about it.
Oh yeah. I'm, I'm, I'm content.
That's when you put it out,
you're in a great position, man,
that you can kind of of decide
what to do and when to do it.
Writing Three of the biggest songs in
the 90s with what is like jump around and
put your lights on. Well that was 2000
I think so, but that little period,
I know and I, I wrote those
songs, jump around with mugs,
what it's like and put your
lights on totally on my own. That,
that provided me with
something that I cherish.
Like some people cherish
private jet rides,
which is I can do whatever the fuck
I want and still live pretty decent.
Not Super Rich Guy or anything,
but like better than average. Oh,
you got a good life.
Take care of my family.
But creatively I could do whatever the
fuck I want and it's a beautiful thing,
man. As I, the older I get like I'm on
my whole new shit. My slogan is, fuck it.
I'm 50 man. That's my new
shit dog. I'm on. Like,
I know you ain't gonna Rattle me, man.
I'm 50 I don't even care. How's that?
If you're, there you go.
I'll just try to have fun.
Live my life. Go home. Hug My kids. Yes.
And fucking know that nobody
fucked with them in school.
And then they had a gray day and there
my universe is complete. Yes. Yeah.
Fucking them 50 fuck it.
I'm 50 yeah. Beautiful.
We need more people to think like
that, man. I'm in time doing.
I had a heart valve
replacement at 28 dude,
I didn't think I was gonna make
35 you know what I mean? Yeah.
So fifties put that microphone in the
chest we ever done in the west. So here,
anybody who don't know this is, this
is a heartbeat. It's not a watch.
It's my heartbeat.
It's like a Goddamn metronome.
Wow.
Well, it's a titanium man.
Wrap your head around that? No,
I got alien technology in my
chest. My to stay together.
Hold the doors, don't fly off that
thing. Click, click, click. That's crazy.
Yeah. It's basically a very simple thing.
It's like a ring that goes in the valve
and it's like a spring kind of activated
flap that is totally self propelled
by the heart's pumping up the blood.
It pumps the blood out of the flap and
then the flap kind of snaps back and
that's what you're hearing is the tic
has just the spring of that and it's all,
I mean, I can take my pulse without
w it would just sit in here.
Do you know what I mean? I can take my
pulse without even thinking about it.
Modern technology is
so amazing. St Jude's,
Val shout out that the St Jude's
people, whoever invented that shit,
bleep up from the motherfucker.
Vega stars is doing whatever they can
figure out a way to make your heart work
again with a fake valve.
Click, click, click.
It's wild and that's why you're
here. That's why I'm still here, man.
It's amazing. I've been wondering
afterwards like why, why did it, why it,
what killed John Ritter?
What killed him was exactly
kind of what happened to me,
but I was able to get to the hospital
faster. Did you ever meet that guy? No,
but I know that like when it happened
though, like people pointed it out. Like,
isn't that what happened to you?
I was like, oh yeah, that one.
It was a special dude. He was
on a, an episode of News Radio.
Everybody loved him, man. Like so
nice. I like wandering around the set,
like friendly to everybody, like in
a weird way, like a, like a, just a,
he's a genuinely really nice guy
who just making sitcoms and um,
when he died I was like, oh
yeah, that's one of them.
Things was just so nice when you
find out that someone that's like,
you feel like us and nothing's going
to happen to him. He's so nice.
And then one day the
clutch, the plush of death.
I was told by the people at the hospital
when I went back to visit once that,
um,
a while after they had
brought me in because it took
them a minute to figure out
what's wrong with me.
The only reason they figured out what
is wrong with me is because my actual
doctor who's is this guy in Beverly Hills,
I'm not gonna say anything cause I don't
know if he wants that. But uh, he, uh,
it was a member on the
board of Cedar Sinai.
So when they brought me in the hospital,
all his records are
computer accessible to them.
So they found out about my history of
like being born with this heart defect and
cause up until then they heard rock
dude, he's a musician. They were like,
all right, how many, how much cocaine did
you do? And all my friends were trans.
I mean, he doesn't do cocaine, you know,
he's not that in there, like going out,
if we give them the wrong drugs, we
can kill him. And then all of a sudden,
like the records came through.
And that's what saved my ass.
That along with the like, uh,
the head of surgery there,
like the guy who like did a double
eight 99 hour surgery came off of one,
told the guys they couldn't do my
surgery because it was too complex.
It's got Dr. William Trento,
he's an amazing person.
He will not mind me shouting him
out. He like goes to South American,
does all these free operations on kids'
hearts. He's a fucking saint. This guys,
I'll tell you off fucking
show some other shitty did.
That'll blow your fucking mind. Like
wow, that's who does that. But he's,
he saved my life and you know,
I've just been, like I said,
I didn't expect to be here.
50. Fuck it. I'm 50 man.
I got two little girls I've
got, it's like a whole,
my whole thing right now is I want to
take my girls like in the next like week
or two over to see him,
just to be like, Yo dude,
these people wouldn't even
exist if it wasn't for you dude.
Like I think I blew his mind
a little bit. Fuck yeah. Wow.
Shout out to all the people who fix
hearts, all those people fix anything,
fix all things. You know, if you
fix shit, fucking salute. Right.
That's a positive thing. Yeah. Fixed.
Don't care if it's a sink or a heart
or you fix it all. Anything in between,
Dude. Yeah. And that
weird fixing shit is good.
Fixing hearts though. That's
like particularly good.
Like when that guy sees
you on TV and shit,
he's probably fixed that in a
minute. But yeah, he probably
thinks that I fixed it up.
Nice. Fixed it up. Nice.
She enjoys music. Thank you.
They enjoy my work. Fuck it.
I'm going to tell this story. I'm
gonna tell it. Here's the story. Okay.
A few years after my heart surgery,
like when I had my heart surgery,
I didn't have, I didn't have medical
insurance. I was young and dumb. Didn't,
you know what I mean? Just
didn't have it. And uh,
so it fucking caused a real fucking,
and it was like half a million dollar
fucking hit. You know what, I, but I,
you know, I didn't declare
bankruptcy. I paid it all.
And I think this dude heard
about that and they are,
I think guys like this must somehow invest
in you when they know they saved your
fucking life. There's something, there's
a connection after that. Like, oh,
that's one of my guy, that's one of my
guys right there. So a few years later,
my mom, when I was young, had a,
I believe Hodgkin's disease of what it
was and she had radiation treatment and
she beat it and all that.
But 20 years later that shit wears
on your heart valves and shit.
She had to have a triple my pass.
Like it was Kinda like, oh shit.
Like I was out on tour, I had to
come home, put her, I was like,
I want that guy to do the surgery just
because I'd, he'd already done mine.
So he does my mom's surgery
and this guy fucking,
I get all the bills, you know, and then
now I'm doing all right. So it was cool.
I could, I get a bill from
the fucking anesthesiologists.
I get a bill from the fucking operating
room and get a bill from the hospital
and get a bill from this. I never got a
bill from this man for my mom's surgery
to just was like, Nah, that
was on me. Wow. Fucking crazy.
Who gets a surgery done on them? Right?
That's an amazing guy. Who's crazy dude.
That's amazing. No, this dude goes,
and then I like started looking into who
he was and this guy goes and does like
fucking tons and tons of like sergeant
surgeries on kids down in South America
and he's just one of them dudes,
man. Your mom on the house.
What? That guy saved
your mom. All that guys.
God bless her.
God bless him. God bless
him. Yeah, man. It's um,
there's nice people out there
that really are, you know,
we were fed this false narrative that
everybody sucks because so many people do
suck. But there's so many people,
it's just a perspective issue.
It's the same reason why
people think the world is flat.
They don't understand
perspective, their perspective.
When you talking about human
beings and 7 billion people,
we're just overflowing with
people. There's so many of us.
There's so many stories
that people sucking,
but it's all perspective issue because
there's so many goddamn people and most
of them are cool and most of them want
to be cool and they would be more cool if
they knew you were going to be
cool. We all agree to be cool.
We can be cool. We can
have a better time here.
We're wasting time with nonsense
and arguments at all and and,
and conflict.
That all could have been disrupted
from the very beginning by everybody.
This is why we need the alien invasion
alien because a lot of people are
invested in our law and a lot of
shit that's meaningless. You know,
we won't even go into it.
We can all infer what they,
what those things are between us
and the audience can do the same.
But what I'm saying is like,
there's just too much fucking bullshit
about dumb shit that we need some kind of
outside fucking focus
that will take us from outside ourselves
and make us focus on something else or
legalize my showroom, which might be
global warming, but that's,
that's not real right now.
Legalize mushrooms moved to Greenland.
Trump's on it. Is there a trick?
[inaudible]
canceled his fucking trip to Denmark
because they said they're not gonna sell
him. Greenland is stuck in Chet now.
He knows what he's doing. Listen,
Trump's going to get his green land
when you I, that fucking thing is like,
I believe you said what? And
then it's like, oh man, I can't.
It's bizarro world. That's all. That's
all people go to Greenland to bow hand,
Dubbo Hunt. I think they bow hunt that,
that gigantic fucking furry thing.
What is that thing called?
The muskox? Google.
Greenland. Muskox you ever see a
mouse? Cox? You want to sell it? What?
I want to see one and now I also want
to know when I'm getting invited for an
elk barbecue. Dude, come
on. I mean I'm gonna,
I'm going to put a kitchen in here,
in this place. I have, I have plans.
I'll tell you I'll come play it at
this. Let me show you a mustache.
100% success rate on bowhunting and green
land on a muskox cause he just walked
right up to him. Oh, you know what
it is because they, they have a,
an instinct protect
themselves against wolves.
So they all huddled together when threats.
So you could just catch them all
in a group. Lympho Huh? Yeah,
but look what they look like
Bro. They didn't even look real.
They look like something metal star
wars. Those are kind of interesting.
But look, go to the side Jamie. Some of
those other images when you see, yeah,
they're like that. Perfect. Like you
see that walking around, you'd be like,
what the fuck is that? And he
was like a Tauntaun. That's it.
Same Lion fucked a elephant.
Fucked a mammoth. What is
that? A buffalo. What is that?
The fuck is that thing. It
was crazy as horns. Wild Mix.
I go buffalo with a Tina Turner wig and
duty can be 150 million degrees below
zero. Those things just chill.
They're just out there eating frozen
grass and kids come from like their
cheekbones to the crazy looking barely
looks like a real thing. Barely.
They're beautiful and apparently
he's good there apparently.
It's fucking fantastic. Yeah,
that's awesome. My friend
Brendan Burns shot one and um,
I think he said he got his either in an
Antarctica you can go to like really,
really cold climates and
get, I think it's like,
is it north northern Canada or somewhere
in northern Canada where you hunt them
where it's crazy. Like you just get on a,
you get to get pulled by g by snowmobiles
or you get pulled by dogs and you go
like way, way, way the fuck out.
Where if you break down, if
your snowmobile breaks down
or if your dogs all die,
you are fucked. I mean,
you are so, so, so, so,
so fucked because there's
nothing man, there's nothing.
There's the occasional polar bear and
these fucking Muskox and they were up
there and they're, they don't
even look like real things.
And you're stumbling across like imagine
going through a white out snow storm to
stumble a cost across
this 2000 pound, enormous,
gigantic,
hairy prehistoric beast that you could
just walk up to and shoot with a bow and
Arrow and eat. That's, that's
what's up there right now.
They're like a remnant of the past,
like to the saber to see
what they like with this.
If the fight with those things, that'd
be crazy. Use it to fuck up other males.
That's what most of those animals,
they're not fighting off
predators with that shit.
[inaudible] related to breeding
and all that. For sure.
They think some of it
is like in some animals,
depending upon how much pressure
they get, um, from, uh, predators,
like elk keep their antlers very late.
They keep their antlers like into
march and April. Uh, because, uh,
a lot of them live around wolves and the
idea is that they need those antlers to
protect themselves from wolves. So
they hold onto them longer than deer do
biology. It's real crazy. Yeah,
dude, we're so lucky. We're so lucky.
We're out here out the
food chain. Oh my God.
Not only out the few chain.
You had to go right down the street
and get a fat stink tenor friend.
He just said on the agenda,
I cannot the seed now and I would like
to do it soon. You know our spot? Yeah.
I'm sparking this man. Oh, you're crazy.
Now, where does he live? On the edge.
Do you have to lie? Oh, I won't do
it. You don't use a lighter? Yeah.
I'm saying, oh, it's right here. Oh, okay.
I thought maybe you were one of those.
I only use a mask and it will play into
the next tune. We're going to do that.
Come off the top. Yeah, they
come off the top. Sorry,
I wasn't even thinking that way. Oh,
it's like a helmet. He kind of thing.
I see. I think they fucked
things up with that.
That bony part in the front above their
eyebrows. They keep those for life too.
It's not like a deer, you know? Good deer
loses their antlers every year. These,
these motherfuckers fucked up here. Do
they? Does this show beautiful
though? They're so beautiful.
Like that one right there, Jamie.
Clickable hair for church right there.
Like above. Above about right there.
Right there. Right there. Click on that.
That's a beautiful creature. I mean,
it's so amazing that nature
can make fish. It can make,
it's a title Buffalo. You can make
that like buffalo or I don't know man.
What is it? Bison related. Ox Ox.
Muskox aren't they all related?
Bison and all that.
I wish I knew the kids. Kids. Facts,
kids. Facts.
Does it say it's cattle often compared
to cattle cow with a big coat.
Yeah. That's a northern cow to
herbivore. Yeah. There you go. Wow.
Furry island cow. Part of
the vote. Bovie day family.
All the species is family
of two towed hooves,
four chambered stomachs
and our herbivores.
So it's like kind of a cow
type thing. Fuck. It's amazing.
[inaudible] mutate them. Nope. Those,
that's what we're supposed
to be right now. Well,
we're supposed to be right now.
Some sort of stupid fucking hairy dumb
ass is run around getting eaten by Shit
with the aliens came
down and said, listen,
let's just plant some of our stuff and
these monkeys and see what we can do.
I'm man, dude, when they coming back
from happened mass, what I'm saying,
when they coming back, probably
pretty soon it gotta be due.
It's been brought up more and more in
the narrative and every time we go to
sleep we wake up in a new universe
and I think along those lines that a,
they're coming, they're on the way right
now. We're just not quite ready yet.
Everlast maybe you are, but some
people are not. Some people,
if the aliens were hovering over
universal studios right now,
guys lose their minds moving down to one
oh one over the Hollywood bowl saying,
well we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll,
we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll,
and those little fucking times is
the end or the beginning or whatever.
It would be amazing. It
would be very interesting.
The whole thing would go
down, you know what I mean?
If it was the end of all the cool.
Yeah. Let's, I mean I'm not incur,
I'm not saying hey, break it off, but
I'm saying if that's what it is it is,
or if it's the next stage of like
enlightenment and fucking, you know,
all that goodness.
What do you think people do if one of
them like hovered over every major city?
You know what?
I think what we're talking about is what
would the majorly religious do because
I think that would affect religious
thought the most. Right off top.
You know what I mean? Besides
the fear of like what are they?
What are they here for? Right.
The first thing was like, Whoa,
a whole bunch of ideology goes
out the fucking window right now.
You know?
So that would cause a lot of panic and
anxiety right there alone. You know,
you tell them your, your, your
whatever story of whatever religion.
I'm not going. Yeah, we didn't
even go there. We were like that.
I like that thing. Let's
look blanket it. Yeah.
It's going to upset a lot of fo. You
know what I mean? Right away. Just like,
oh my God, that's not what we thought
existed. We're the center of everything.
You know, I think it would happen.
I think people would just start fucking
flat earthers go out the window right
away. That's is over.
Maybe like the aliens travel
here from another dimension,
they have a new explanation for it.
[inaudible] the thing about like being
a flat earth or the thing about any kind
of like thing that you could decide was
already proven is that it doesn't matter
what the facts are anymore. What
matters is what people agree to.
That's what's interesting about it.
Like you realize that there's like a
certain number of people you need to have
to start a community and it
doesn't have to make sense.
You just have to have enough
people that agree to it.
If enough people agree to it,
you can, uh, you can push,
you can push some pretty preposterous
ideas through and a bunch of people hop on
board and they're happy to be on your
group. That's the problem of groups.
The problem with groups is
people would just join groups.
Isn't that the big lie? The big lie
there? They're being lie thing. Their
whole mind comp. Yup. Big Lie theory.
I believe that's theory. Oh Dyke where I'm
quoting that from. But I mean even
if you think about a country, right?
You think about a country
and you think about America,
which we both love and live in. Yes sir.
W It's what is it? You
know, it's an idea, right?
It's an idea.
It's an idea that everybody who's
in this thing is cool to each other.
Everybody's in this thing as part
of a team. That's really what it is.
Bring us your broken mass and all
that stuff from them in front of the,
from the Statue of Liberty.
Some more. I've been thinking,
I think about this thing, your huddled
masses is that that am I getting it?
It's been a while and I know
I'm 50. You know what I mean?
You're saying it's um, like whatever.
We are like B, we are what we
agree we are. We are all, we agree.
We are like we don't,
it's most of what we're in
conflict about is fucking stupid.
And as a country like
we're supposed to be a,
we're supposed to agree that
we're all in this together.
So if we're all in this together,
it should be good for everybody.
We could do that. We could do that
better than we think we can. Way better,
way better after. The problem is the
conflict. Some of it's unnecessary, man,
boom.
That's a good sound effect
for that month. Perfect.
It's, you know, some of it is just
unnecessary in these these moments, man.
It's moments when we have fun
moments, when we get together,
moments when we hug moments when
we'll have a drink together, homeless,
we'll listen to some music moms when
we're all leaving a concert together,
a movie together that we realize like
Raul in this together, we're all right.
It's just like, can we just got to
navigate it better? That's all it is.
We're crashing into each other.
I honestly, he goes, he moments we
mourn together. I mean honestly, I mean,
I hate to say this but you know,
I've see a lot of my older friends,
more funerals lately than other events
and, but they turned into celebrations,
if you know what I mean. Cause we all
understand like, all right man, well, Hey,
I'm glad I am seeing you right
now. Let's fucking, yeah, you know,
and whoever it was that we're
celebrating definitely doesn't want that.
They want this for sure.
I know when I go party the fuck up
party fuck up and say like, yeah,
God did. I did. I, he did. Was
a pretty good dad ever. You,
I've made a few bucks, made a
few bucks. That's Dana Man. Dana,
just play that song no matter what I man
got love. I gotta get my 25 sets, man.
I gotta get my 20 slap sets
every episode, dog. Man, come on.
You begrudge me my 25 cents. I love it.
I was walking out of the Octagon, I
forget who, uh, who I was interviewing.
My favorite is this, every once in awhile,
like there's a few people who choose
that song. Like, uh, Cynthia Cub.
Kavio well, let's get out. Shout out
to the first. Marcus Davis. Yeah.
Marcus Degas. He did.
He did the first day and then
he went into the Trump around.
But some people every once
in a while, I don't know,
maybe if they a bad song or something
like out of nowhere, out of nowhere.
One time like Leo Machida came out to
jump around and I'm like, I texted dean,
I was like, who the fuck
picked daddy? He's like, I did.
And he said [inaudible] he didn't
go any further. And I was like,
oh he must've picked the song. Dana
hated her so well. Some of these cats,
they'll choose music and Jan, it was
like, Nah. And I think the Goto Jam,
if you fucking picks
it up, he doesn't like
cause I'll be like, that was
random man. I was like, how did,
how did that happen? It's funny.
It's funny when there's a
song that plays all the time,
it connects you to one of your friends.
It's like as I'm walking out
of the octagon, it's like, eh.
There was a period of about six
years where anywhere Dana was,
it could be, I could be, he could be
on this side of world. I'm sleeping,
so I'd get a phone call and it'd
just be a phone in the air at a club.
People play. I feel like, dude, come on.
You guys nailed that song so hard.
There's like moments in space time
that get nailed. Just like you, you,
you just hit something that
resonates with people. I uh,
I, uh, I, I still, uh, Danny's
quote Danny Boy's quote of, uh,
it's the Louie Louie of the 90s.
It's the way little, it's just there.
It's part of the like, it's,
it's almost not mine anymore.
It's like belongs to the universe.
It's weird. Every ball game I go to,
any event I go to, it gets played.
And it's not even like a big deal about,
it's like some places it's a big deal.
Like you get these football games,
college shit like Wisconsin's and stuff
where it's like part of a tradition.
What I'm saying,
any event or an angels game or dodger
game or Yankees game or Laker game or
football game, it's, it pops
up somewhere along the line.
You're right up there with queen.
It's crazy. It's wild. I mean,
as you're talking about songs like
individual songs and their imprint on
something, it's bananas. It's, it's,
it's something to like, I can't,
you can't almost invest your thought
in it because it can get like, whoa,
it's really kind of a part
of, of of pop culture.
It's ingrained on a,
uh, on, on an America.
It's an American
phenomenon. And worldwide.
I mean like worldwide.
I mean, where did you,
can you go where they probably never
heard jump around. It's weird. I mean,
to think about it on that level is crazy.
Maybe like one of them places
where Trump's trying to
buy maybe up in Greenland.
No, no, they heard it. They heard it.
Queen had, we are the
champions and, and, and uh,
it also had, we will rock you.
Those are two of the greatest
sports anthems of all time.
Queen nailed two of them. Like one
of the fucking Panas do of them.
We will rock you and we are the
champions. It's actually the same song.
Two is the same song, isn't it?
Yeah. They blend into each other.
Different songs. They kind of, they're,
they're technically connected.
He had to buy them on iTunes.
You have to buy two songs I think.
Is it a slash in there? Is it?
Or we will rock you. We are the champions.
They come together on the record.
When the record came out, they went
right back to back. Yeah, it doesn't,
there's no space three or
was it recognized as one
individual song? The label,
it was listed as two different titles.
Two different titles. You're not,
you're not miked up, people can't hear
you. So I'm trying to, oh sorry. Yeah,
here you go. Here we go. Sorry DJ man.
So that was actually one of the
first albums I got when I was a kid.
But on the actual label, which
has like the titles of the songs,
they were listed as two different
titles. But on the actual vinyl,
the surface of the
record, it was one groove.
So the songs just went
right into each other. So,
so if you were in a diner and you put
like those quarters in that thing and you
played that right, give you one
song or would he give you no,
it usually gives you both. It
gives you both. Good question man.
For Man, diner music. I
was listening to my memory.
That microphone. I feel like
my memory, I'll share with you.
We share where I feel like my memory,
I see like a we will rock you slash we
are the champions thing like going on and
[inaudible] it's like,
I feel like you would've got both
songs cause they don't remember.
There is no stop. There's not even
a clean place to edit it really.
If I'm right. It's crazy
that it's two songs.
Do you remember those wheels of the diners
in the east coast and when they roll
it's kind of where the
champion, oh so it's two songs,
one song, two songs, but it's one. So I
was just driving a year 45 it only has,
we will rock you on one side. That's,
I was driving a u haul truck last
weekend. I'm in the process of moving.
So all you had while
we had was amfm radio.
So I was listening to k Earth one-on-one
and we will rock you came on and right
away came we are the champions.
So I played it as one song now.
Well they go together, you
know, perfectly percent.
It seems like it's almost, but it is
clearly two different jams. Right?
It's great.
Similar themes like goddamn wizard
wacky. We are the champions.
That band they were,
they were really sorcerers know he
was amazing. Freddy Mercury was wow.
He was amazed. He was crazy.
He was on your vocal on stage.
Just a masterpiece of Bohemian rhapsody
alone. It's just crazy. I know, right?
Like can you think of like rock albums
and you think of songs and you think of
that one. You're like, why?
Like I write these little three chord
songs with a nice story over and shit and
this month this dude was
doing like fucking 16 part
harmonies of bis mill long.
No, we will not let you go.
Like wrote like a rock opera,
like within four or five
minutes. It was fucking bananas.
How genius that Shit is. It's great to
listen to like it's super entertaining.
It's captivating. He was a damn
God damn hero. Yeah,
for sure. Right Freddy?
Yeah. This isn't, I
haven't seen the movie.
I wouldn't to say I haven't
seen the movie though.
After they stopped having fucking
[inaudible] do it. I'm like, I'm out.
We're see. Cause I like, I liked the
show. That guy's on that Mr. Robot.
I'm sure I'd like him to,
but it doesn't matter that you tease
me with Allie g and then you pull them
away. I don't know. I mean
that's not why I didn't see it.
I just haven't had the chance.
But I heard that bore out wanting to
do a lot of like a crazy dre. He was,
yeah, he probably wanted to do all the,
you wonder, have dongs flapping around.
You know what I mean? He wanted all
that. He wanted to go the other,
he wanted to go the dark side of
Freddy who wanted to be buck wild.
I'm sure the guy who
did it did a great job.
The problem is whenever someone gets
attached to the idea of someone else doing
it and then the new guy comes
in, he's forever tainted,
but if you haven't and you ever
go on t v Little Show binges,
that guy's show, Mr. Robot is really
good. It's pretty fucking good.
Pretty fucking good. I've heard it's
really fun. It's fucking like bizarre,
like futuristic hacker weirdness.
It's fucking, it's pretty dope too.
This is the best time ever. If
you want to just sit and watch TV,
like is there a better time that's
ever existed? Dude, get smoke weed.
It's legal. Just sit. Watch
42 episodes of a show.
I don't curse too much this behavior,
but occasionally I think it's important
and probably even therapeutical,
but if you could just sit down
and watch something on TV,
there's more shit to watch today than
the human race has ever seen, ever.
That's a fact.
Then make a new TV shows every goddamn
minute they're happening right now.
They're putting them out on Hulu.
They're putting them out on Amazon.
They're putting them out on Netflix.
They don't even stagger them now they
drop an entire season tickets out,
watch it, deal with it, deal with it.
Bitch. You watched stranger things? Yes,
I'm an episode five. Don't tell me Shit
of what the most reasons seasoning.
Everybody's skish. It's good.
It's good. I enjoy it. I enjoy it.
I can't tell you I enjoy it. No, I
ain't going to tell you anything else.
A little bit better than good. I'll
tell you a couple of good ones.
I enjoy a couple of good ones. I
enjoy you. Fuck with Ozark. Oh Dude,
do I fuck. Okay. There we go. There's
Ozar, man. What did I give up one?
It wouldn't be Ozar. They canceled it,
but the seasons that exist
are fucking hilarious.
You have you watched this
Santa Clarita Diet? No,
it's with Drew Barrymore and
I'm the guy from Timothy.
Timothy Ola fan from like
a deadwood. That Guy Yo.
It's like I w I'm not even
gonna say anything else but yo,
y'all can come thank me
later. Go check that shit out.
It's like two seasons of it and
they canceled it for some reason.
Hopefully they'll bring it back
if a lot of enough people like it.
But I'm telling you,
it's fucking hilarious.
It's like if you like
Zombie kind of weirdness,
but it ain't really scary and it's
fucking hilarious is what it is.
It's craziness. Beautiful. If you ever
watched the unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt,
I have not got to watch that. Check it
out. That is a god damn a Larry Show.
That's a good to sit down with
your wife because you'll laugh.
Your ass always look shells. She'll
love it. Listen, it's hilarious.
It's about a lady who, uh,
was in a call and she got locked up in a
basement for like 13 years and then she
got out. She doesn't know
what the fuck anything is,
but she's hilariously optimistic.
It's really [inaudible] on this one.
It's not that,
but it's like this lady like chick comic
and I don't remember her name and I
don't know them. They show right
now, but it's fucking hilarious.
And she's like a Larry. David is
chick. Like she's Larry. David ask,
I should say like the show is like,
she's always like the fucking mom who's
like fucking doing some crazy shit.
There's like an episode of like where
there's a mom amongst the crew that's like
done porno and so all the moms
are talking about, but like,
the fucking show's hilarious. I
gotta. Oh man, I can't remember.
You know what that is, Jim? I've got
to think of the show. Who's in it?
What are the actors? I don't
know. That's what I'm saying.
I've watched it with my wife sometimes
and I'm just gonna get the name of it
real quick while we're here.
No, no, it's definitely,
definitely uh, uh,
it's some like no apologies or a pot.
Something about apology. Sorry. Not,
sorry. Okay. Fucking
shit is hilarious, dude.
That lady is fucking hilarious. Was
that, I don't know her name. I'm sorry,
but savage. There you go. She's sound
savvy. She's fucking funny duty.
This savage to show is
pretty sad, but it's like,
it's like some dirty Larry David
kind of fives. Kind of a burden.
Do you have with a name like
savage, like you had to produce.
You can't run around and be lazy
with it and you can't, you can't.
You gotta bring it. Bob Savage,
savage sitting there
smelling his own farts. What?
Jamie's got a panic. I googled that.
I just googled that. Sorry. Not Sorry.
With the man of savage now,
like nothing came up then. Oh,
that's what your article up there. That's
definitely it because I've known my,
I was why I was saying apologies
or something. Sorry. No, sorry.
Article I had there she goes, that's
her. Oh, she's fucking hilarious. On her.
Unapologetic new comedy
could find, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that the show is called.
I'm sorry. The arms are titled, sorry,
not sorry. There you go. I knew it was
an apology or something like that. God,
it's fucking hilarious. We're doing this
research that has this kind of reach,
but you guys are winging it. It's kind
of what a lot of ways, dude, like,
I mean, it's kind of beautiful.
It's the beauty of the show though.
A little bit the same as 100% winged. He
goes with us. I'm sitting a little bit,
but yeah,
don't be scared of homie.com shout
out to Nate Diaz. Victorious.
Shout out to Anthony Pettis. Gladiator
the good fight. It was great fun.
I totally agree with the outcome.
Yes. Oh definitely. Definitely Nate.
Nate won that fight for sure. I was,
I was complimented when I walked into
Dana's green room and was told I smelled
like I just came from
needy. It's his camp.
It was amazing. I have it. I love
that. Thank God for that guy.
Fucks given his like at an all time. No,
all time low. Thank God for that guy.
He's so important. Just be you. Yeah.
Love that car. That's what he's doing.
I mean he and he's fighting for the
baddest motherfucker at one 70 right? Yes,
yes. Yeah. Fuck. Cutting
weight. His need to cut weight.
But I love what he's talking
about fighting for the
baddest motherfucker in the
game.
Oh my goodness. So that's the belt he's
referring to. Okay. Cause I was like,
this was for a belt and there's only
three rounds. I was like, wait a minute.
I'm just so confused
thinking about. I was so,
I was a little high and drunk myself
thinking about trying to get them to
explain that to people, but I was like,
I'm gonna just let him go. I don't,
I don't even want to get
in the way of [inaudible].
I'm glad I know now what
belt he's talking about.
He's talked about it multiple
times. That's a great
fight. He called down, said,
dad, he said, defend this
belt. And I was like, yeah,
okay. He's talking about the baddest
motherfucker in the game belt.
I thought he was going to say it, but I,
I probably should have
asked him what belt it was.
No, it's more beautiful like that.
There's like this. No, it's perfect.
It's like an Easter egg.
[inaudible] what a great name.
The baddest motherfucker in the game belt.
We should be so happy.
That guy's a real thing.
We should be so happy in that
fight. It would be amazing.
Yeah, man. That would be incredible.
Mazda dolls, a straight up murderer.
He's a straight up murderer.
Toes Nate. That'd be chaos.
That'd be chaos if then
those two guys want to do it.
Those are two mean just
wild dogs going at it.
Those guys are both like
to the core. They're there.
They're fighters to the core. There's
no quit in either one of those guys.
I mean that's a wild fight, man.
Especially right now, like financially,
that's an amazing fight right now.
People would pay a lot of
money to see that fight.
Mazda Dal and Nate Diaz there.
Those are two guys that are like the most
exciting and most talked about guys in
the sport right now. If those guys
decided to fucking smash horns, Woo.
Good. It looked like they were more
than willing. Yeah, I hope to make that.
That would be, that would be an amazing
fight. Hope to make that happen.
That'd be God Damn Bananas and maybe
one of us will come out to turn around
if they pick something shitty enough. No,
at their level.
I think they get to pick their own
music as long as they don't have,
like we were talking about,
wait, wait. But Leo, Leo Machida,
I want to know the story behind that.
One day I'm going to corner day and
everyone were like, you know, when this,
when he's not the fucking busiest dude
on earth and, and be like, what the fuck?
What happened? What Song did
he pick? And you were mad,
which the auto fight was that? I don't
know man. I'm sure somebody knows.
I wonder if he won cause that will be
interesting. I think fuck was vibe.
I'm not sure.
I think he did because I keep track
of shit like that cause it's fucking,
I hate it almost when somebody, because
one of my favorite guys, um, uh,
oh my God, uh, the beard, uh,
super duper friends with
Tate. Uh, thank you.
Mean the dean of mean, do you know KCI
Giardia? He came out to my version of,
of fucking, uh,
Folsom prison and I was so jacked about
it and he lost that fight and I felt
like it made me feel horrible.
Like, Oh man, my, Oh,
this is Chris Weidman when he fought
Liotta cheat. Oh, that's what it was.
That's when the auto c you put the
Kabash on Liotta. Oh, so he, yeah, he,
let's see. See I took was, look man,
I didn't ask for that
fucking ass for that dude.
I don't need that pressure. That wasn't
going to say come pick my shit song.
Wasn't gonna save him. You know what I
mean? That's one of those weird ones.
It's like, what is,
how bad is the song that you won't
let a person pick their own songs?
That's what I want to know. It's not
that much time. I mean, it's only like a,
the walk to the ox guys, not a full song.
It's not like three minutes, but it,
all those Brazilian guys always come
out today, eh, eh. You know what I mean?
Like fucking a, they can come
up to the fucking loudest music.
Some of those dudes,
not dax murderer used to come out to
some real questionable fucking like touch
disco house.
He came out to like rock tech. You
crazy. Oh my God. Yeah, that's right.
Dutch does Swedish house Mafia.
Oh my God, you're so right. Crazy.
That's exactly what he's coming
out to though. [inaudible] like
overtly like over the top two. Number one.
Worst dorm number one worst walkout song.
My favorite was when Randy coture
came out to Ted Nugent stranglehold.
I was like, if there is ever a
song that's like design like that,
that seems like a fun fight playing song.
You know like you're
about to have a fight.
That's the song you want plant
stranglehold. Michael Kia sees that too.
A couple of guys he just trying to hold
now that's a song like stranglehold and
it's one of those songs.
Anything by AC DC. Oh yeah.
Thunderstruck come out to a fight.
Cool. Yeah, just that good Angus.
His tone on the guitar, it's
over. You got anger, right?
Got some nice
rich Franklin used to come out the
thunderstruck when he was the middleweight
champion
does that. This came up to, I know he
definitely came out to an ACDC song.
Now I think shit is, it feels like right.
Questioning that was big
like right then to, yeah,
AC DC is like one of those bands where
you hear like three or four chords.
You're like ac DC like instantly,
like for Angus young again,
this guitar tone just as what's
called for those about to rock. Oh,
he came up to ask for those ABAP
to come out to a fender struck too.
I think when he fought Anderson
Silva, you're about to find this.
Guess he won 26 he did the for
those about which a fight was that?
Who was he fighting?
I think for sure he came out the
thunderstruck cause school is your friend.
He was a, he was an DC dude. Oh,
well he fought for his girlfriend.
He was at ac DC. Dude,
you think about w walk out music as
big as it was. It's a nice someone.
Their walkout music was that chuck
Liddell, he beat with a broken arm,
like Chaz kicked him in the arm broken.
I think. I feel like I was there,
but I might not, I might just even seen
it on TV. He caught his on where it was.
I don't know. Chuck broke his arm
in the first round and then he, um,
he clipped him with a
punch with his other hand,
like when everybody should with a broken
arm. That was crazy. Yeah, same song,
UFC 72. Okay. Maybe that was the
song for those about to rock. Hmm.
Great Song. Either way. Like
I, I, when everybody hit me,
I apparently when Steve pay
knocked out DC, like there's a,
that angle where I was like, Oh, you saw
me? And then like recently I saw the,
did you ever see the meme with Khabib
where he's like staring at counter?
Like after knocking out fucking,
I think it's a Josie and like it's me,
like I'm like talking
to like fucking cubby,
but he's just staring like this and like
there's a meme that just like focuses
in on him. Like it's fucking crazy
side. Like it's got me thinking like,
I wonder how I'd be, like I said,
I've been to so many of these fucking
fights that I don't even, you know,
I was like trying to remember and it's
like, I can't even remember. Yeah.
You've been coming to him almost as long
as I've been working for the UFC. Yeah,
basically close to it. Not as,
but Clo in the neighborhood.
Know what I mean? A couple
of years behind. Yeah. Yeah,
but like you know the first guy ever
smoked pot indoors with in Vegas.
We just smoke pot here.
I was like a little kid.
I think when I say where did they
going to go? What are they going to go?
He's like, go, hey, where are you
going to do a club? And I was like,
all right dude.
[inaudible]
somebody had made a meme that says
something about even his concentration and
he, I started focusing in on him like
this. It was hilarious. Make that bigger.
Does it make it bigger? Is it
possible to make it bigger?
Let me tell you something.
Listen, look at Khabib's face.
Is there a harder man that's ever lived?
Look at that and be tell you though.
He came out like two fights before
that fight and he was the nicest guy to
everybody that came up to
him. Oh, he's like, he,
everybody came to me engage
with them, talk to them.
Soon as the Conor fight
was about to happen.
That was it for the whole,
he just was watching Connor
the whole time and, and like,
and like we were talking like he
like in the whole time, like I said,
we were engaged in what I'm saying to
him right there. I was like, Oh shit,
y'all probably fighting kind of thing.
Cause he was like, I want
to fucking fight that guy.
And they got into it
backstage at that shit.
Wow.
But I was just made me laugh and it
made me start thinking like, hey,
I wonder how much shit I want to, how
much shit I Mike in the background of,
you know what I mean?
A ton of them. One of the best
ones ever is Aryan Dunkin kissing.
And when they planned it, they
planned it. So these guys,
pat the camera passed in front of him
and they grab each other and started
making out just so they could be
on camera. Watch this, they'll get,
watch this right here.
The camera pans to them.
Oh Shit. Oh my God.
And Dana. Dana texted me
afterwards. Did your friends fuck
[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh man. Oh Shit. What's
up? What's up Jamie?
I thought I was with them at that fight
and it might've been on a substance
psychedelic. Oh, they
probably were wavy. Yeah,
they probably were that that was common
practice. Common practice in the day.
One of Bang. One more on this.
Do it. Let's do it. Let's do a,
I'm smoking and drinking. So
that seems appropriate. Yes,
sure.
All right, DJ Melody. Uh, and,
and let's one more, give
a little shout out it,
him and the beat Junkies have a
school in Glendale, California.
It's called beat Junkies Institute
of sound. They teach kids,
youngsters and grownups how to DJ
like properly, like real djs. Yeah.
Beautiful beat junkies.
By the way. This is real
people just listening
turntables. This isn't some
bullshit. This is like,
you backed me up on
that real shit. Does he?
Russell Peters and proves
right show. So [inaudible]
[inaudible]
she advised all there. Then all
of a sudden find [inaudible] soap.
Dog is day should tell me.
Last summer [inaudible] cousin
got themselves locked away,
cooking match trim and
Siemens sound post them.
And just Americana sample pack as
[inaudible] as strata,
all sort of trickle
into prayers. If you got
[inaudible]
and train again to waste and man
no where man shit smelled
to waste and
[inaudible] they're all with
[inaudible] whisky, the whole attitude.
[inaudible]
the boots have dab in there. So go
ahead, grab it. I'm a chrome plated man.
[inaudible] all have friends.
[inaudible] and drank
it two ways there that
[inaudible] Shh,
whoa.
That's a great fucking song.
Whitey Ford sings a Whitey Ford's
house of pain is the latest album.
Let me do all the things my manager
will slap me later for if I don't, uh,
o g Everlast you can find me on Instagram
and that's the only I really do.
But I'm on the Facebook and all
that with all detours and all that.
But if you want to see what
I talk about or what I do,
it's Oji ever last on Instagram.
Um, I got Joe started on Instagram,
by the way. That's 100% and he's
kicking my ass out over there.
He's got like 18 million
followers. I got like a 98,000
I always, dude, no,
always. That's another,
you're people always come and are
always beautiful folks. That's still,
that's 100% because of
the room. But uh, but the,
the folks that always come after a
podcast are always like, find folks and,
and, and are enthusiastic.
It's awesome to hear.
I think we tapped into a river of cool
people. I think they're out there.
I think you put it out there and people
respond in turn and they realize that a
lot of,
a lot of the shittiest behavior that
we all exhibit is because we're around
shitty behavior for making
agreement to be nice to each other.
We can change everything. I'm
working on it. We are, I'm a dead
Jack. You're a man and
you're Irish. I'm a dick.
I'm looking for a quick excuse to
be one. If you want to be an ass,
you know what I mean? He'd be, but you
know, and all the years now, no, you,
you're a very, very introspective
guy, man. You look at yourself,
you know when people make mistakes and
they look at themselves like you're, uh,
you're a guy who looks at everything,
man. You look at yourself,
you look at other people.
It's nice to be afforded the time
and luxuries to do such things too.
Let's acknowledge it. Some people,
hey man, motherfuckers still got,
some people can barely
look up from the grind man.
It's a blessing to be able to like
have that, those moments of like, hey,
whatever it is, Joe Rogan in the fucking
brush, you know, stalking and elk,
that's where he gets his moment. Or
you know, or whatever. Me, you know,
driving fucking Pacific coast
highway, listen to in a beat,
trying to fucking come with an idea.
You know what I mean? That's a luxury.
You know what I mean? Even
though it's hard work,
you might be thinking of a joke out
there while you're fucking [inaudible].
You know what I mean? Now we're lucky.
Super Lucky for sure. Well said.
That's so important to acknowledge,
you know, for everybody and,
and we didn't use to be, and
that's, that's the grind, you know?
And we're all okay. We're all okay.
We just got to figure out way
through our own individual Mays.
The problem isn't comparison. Right.
That's a big part of the problem. I,
I'm totally paraphrasing,
but there's like definitely a
famous phrase where it's like,
comparison is the death of joy and I
think we've even talked about it on,
they might, I'm having Deja Vu,
so they might've been on here that we
talked about that I'm a repetitive fuck.
Yeah. And I say a lot of the
same shit over and over again.
That's a Thomas Jefferson quote.
Correct? Comparison is the thief of joy.
Thief of joy. I think we
have talked about it my days.
Who is in high gear right now?
It's one of my favorite quotes because
it just makes you realize like this is
something you can't even control,
like you're, you're concentrating on,
she also can control, I feel
like it's like there's this,
everybody's not entitled to the luxury
that we're talking about. So it's like,
it's,
you gotta be thankful for it on an extra
high level because it seems like we're
in this twisted thought age where it's
like everybody thinks they that and I
don't even feel like I deserve it. I'm,
I'm lucky I'm a fortunate fucking man.
You know what I mean? I, I sing songs,
I always compare it to like this. Like,
you know, when you talk, you know,
when like people are talking about
the old new music, whatever, whatever,
I'm like, whatever happens, if the
lights go out and all the power goes out,
I can go from fucking little fucking
prefecture to prefecture and play a little
song for you and get a meal from me
and my family. That's how I equate it.
Like it's, it's a trade, you
know what I mean? And, and it's,
it's an imbalanced society that
gives, that has be, I mean, I,
I've met teachers that I feel like should
be making way more fucking money than
me, man. Like on real levels that I, that
I've seen do things for kids on like,
you know, like my school has
a mixture. Like, you know,
kids that go there because they lived
there and then there's a lot of people
trying to go to school cause it
was very nice school. But you know,
so there's imbalances and these,
I've seen teachers like come out their
own pockets and do things for people that
was like, wow man, that's,
you know what I mean?
I like to think I do nice
things and I think I do,
but I'm saying it's like when I see it
on a level where it's like grassroots
ground level, it's, it's impactful to me.
Yeah, it's too, you know,
when you think about teachers,
that's the one that's the
heartstring puller. You know,
like how much teachers make, you
hear about the rocks to how do you,
you're taking care of our baby is you're
teaching our babies and you hear about
the bad ones here about the mean
teachers that fuck would a kid's head.
You don't realize it. They don't realize
what they're doing to the kid. Like,
oh some people are just
angry. This is angry in me.
And it comes out in their teaching.
And if your teacher gets
stuck or your kid rather,
if your kid gets stuck
with one of those teachers,
like that can have a devastating
impact on the kid's life.
We're, we're, we're,
we're experiencing like something like
that but not on a mat on a very minor
level of like, you know,
like, um, the way the school,
we just found out like today, yesterday,
like what teachers our kids have,
you know what I mean? It's like
there's the whole like, um, cultural,
parents' circle of knowing who's teaching
which teachers you want and which ones
you don't, you know what
I mean? So it's like,
I'm not going to go into whether
we got what we wanted or not,
but it's like the fucking drama by, and
it is, it's a Laramie to me. It's like,
it's such a, it's such a
like, whoa, like, yeah.
Is there abuse going on or why, you know,
when teachers a little more strict
than the other? I, in my day,
my parents would've said like,
that's the teacher we want nowadays.
It's almost like the opposite.
I mean that in an old days,
my mom would been like, that's district
or teacher yet, put them in that class,
put them in that class, cause that's
the one that's not gonna take any shit.
And that's the one that's going
to get, you know, tell him,
make sure he knows and people aren't
going to take shit from him and like,
you know what I mean? And that's, I
understand that mentality. You nowadays,
it's almost the flip like, oh, that
teacher's like, she just so, you know,
abrasive too. It's like,
well what does she do? Well,
she raised her voice to the kid.
That was, what was the kid doing?
He was fucking losing his mind in
class. So the teacher raised their toys.
There's that, you know,
it's just a general example
here, but, well, I, it's hilarious. And
we got paddled. Yeah. Paddled at school.
I got in a fight with a kid named
Preston banks. We duked it out. Well, no,
we were like got paddle. I was like, fuck.
I lived there from 11 and 13
so somewhere in that range.
They fucking whacked me in there.
Florida, Florida. Yeah. Yeah, Florida,
they used to be a lot of powder
you this dude had a paddle,
like an actual wooden paddle and me and
this kid got in a [inaudible] this I
remember thinking even though I was
probably like 11 or 12 or whatever it was,
when I got in a fight with this kid,
I realized this kid had been like badly
burned when he was young and we were,
you know,
we're in school together and he was like
missing part of his ear and his neck
was all fucked up. And I was
thinking like, oh, this guy,
like he's not doing so well like
this is, it made me realize like we,
we got into this little scrap
over nothing because it just,
he wasn't doing so well and
I didn't realize that until
I was in the principal's
office with them and the fight,
like we couldn't fight in front of the
principal. That was the authority figure.
We were both like subdued, but I
was realizing when I was around the,
but this isn't a mean
guy. He's a sad guy. Like,
he's the guy that just didn't get any
love and he feels like you got ripped off
by life cause he got burned when
he was a little kid for sure.
And it made me think like it, it
changed the way I looked at people.
But then one little argument fight
with one kid and then getting paddles,
getting paddled just
cemented it like out there.
I don't agree with it, you know?
And the guy didn't hurt me.
He didn't try to hurt me and tried
to hurt the other duty either.
But he definitely paddled us. He used
to be, it used to be a legal thing,
staying on it, man. You know what I mean?
That's what we grew up with. You guys.
I got spanked her, but
it's that good I think.
I think there's appropriate time
in place. I really do for girls.
I don't know about that. That's different.
Cause I have two girls and I've never,
I've never spanked my kids and
I don't think I threatened to,
but I've never had to actually commit
and do it. Uh, so I don't know.
Yeah, no, it's,
it seems like that might not be the
right and even when the boy I'm talking
about that physical justice for me,
she would be a rare thing.
Let me give you an example of when like
a time in my life when I definitely
deserve physical justice and
got it. My father, you know,
I was using guns when I was very
young. We'd go out and shoot and like,
not hunting necessarily,
but he'd take us out and shoot in the
mountains out in the Angeles for us back
in the day. And like fucking,
I had a very good gun
education and understanding
of guns and one time when they
were away,
I fucked around with his like pumped
shotgun and fucking accidentally fucking
loaded it and fucking bang and
shot into the wall. All right.
This was an apartment
too. This wasn't a house.
This was in an apartment building. Now.
It wasn't a wall connected to in another
apartment, but put the possibilities,
you know what I mean? When they came,
uh, a few hours later that apartment
outside was surrounded by police,
like with guns. Like, they
didn't know what happened.
The neighbors all called cops,
didn't they heard a shotgun?
But so after they all
settled it down and shit,
I got my ass fucking kicked that
last, that night on my father.
You know what I mean? And you know,
some people nowadays would say
that's fucking rough, but no,
I fucking could have fucking killed
a human being easily. I'd just,
you need sometimes no, like, okay,
this is because what you just did
could have wound you up in fucking the
penitentiary for the rest of your life.
So an ass kicking doesn't seem as extreme
as you think when you put it in the
balance of that. So when you're getting
to like a level of that, I think,
especially for a boy, you
know what I mean? And I, I've,
I don't know if [inaudible] girl
was going that wowed. I mean, I,
I would encourage the mom to
throw the beginning. I mean,
a dad can't throw that beating,
you know, it'd be a little rough.
But I think there's a time and
a place where like, hey you,
if you're going to stop you, you
gotta let them know and here's,
this will be the rest of your life.
If you keep down this path, that's,
it's gotta be that extreme to me
for it to be a beating nowadays.
When I was young, a beating could
come from talking back. Right.
At least a smack in the face. Yeah.
Well that's, you know, a shoe.
Just a little of my, if it was mom,
after like 13 moms stopped using
the hands, cause you know it then,
you know, I had outgrown her. She,
my mom was little, my mom was little,
almost a little woman, like
four foot 11, five foot tops.
That's just throwing shit. Oh yeah. So
after awhile I was like, it went from,
it went from the hands to like
a stirring spoons and shit.
And then once those started breaking,
it became shoes and like, you know, uh,
whatever else, broomstick.
And then it became like with to your
fucking father gets home and mom might've
like gently smacked me
upside the head gently,
like never like a real like wound,
you know, my mom was a Brooklyn Lady.
She might've been like,
what are you doing? Stupid.
I never got my dramas tried
to forever drop me. Ma.
I remember being like nine or 10 and mom's
chasing me down the block catching me
and fucking
like dead ass beat up in front of it.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Happens to happen. The worst had
happened. My mom was not chasing me.
She'd be like, you're coming home
eventually dummy. My mom wasn't,
I mean she wasn't having that. No. Oh
word. My mom would've never chased me.
She would be like, I'm not playing your
games. She's little. But she was fast.
She was fast. She caught you beat
your ass in front of your friends.
So rough when you're young
boy and you try to be cool.
It's like the most embarrassing.
Like any day you can just trip on your
own Dick and fall face to do a fence like
a fucking asshole. Just so
goofy. I think it actually
made some more friends at the time
understand me a little bit differently.
Do like, oh wow dude.
Alright. Like yeah, for sure.
We get you now we understand kind of
your whole thing. Like you're Steve,
like you're, you guys
are nuts. Yeah, for sure.
But don't you like when you think of
yourself as like a musician, an artist,
like you're so fortunate,
this is going to sound weird,
but you're so fortunate to
come from a chaotic upbringing.
I feel like everyone who I know that
comes from some sort of a chaotic
upbringing has like a different kind of
like horsepower to their shit. You know,
like all my favorite people that I like
to listen to and watch y'all at some
like real fucked up moments
and struggles and chaos.
I'm sure madness. You don't,
you don't get what you put out without
that. That's like the root of it all.
That's the seed that
causes it all to grow.
I mean it's similar to a joke,
a song you're trying to find.
It depends on what you know.
Whenever you you take from it.
I like to call it the highest common
denominator like that. I'm trying to find,
it's like the, the the highest
level thing we can all connect on,
you know what I mean? Not the basis,
most lowest level or common denominator.
I'm trying to find the word. What kind
of elevated level can I speak to you on?
Even if it's about fuckery,
can I raise the level of speaking about
it and just telling a tale about it
without it, you know, being, you know,
again the most basin and and easiest
lowest hanging fruit [inaudible] yeah.
You know, that's the same thing. I think
with the joke you're trying to find,
there's no real new,
like you're just finding new angles
on funny shit. You know what I mean?
Like things are news when things are
newly invented or when there are new
events,
like it has to be like a significant
event or a new invention then then things
open up new pathways. Other than that,
like you're talking about relationships.
You're doing a variation of exactly take
on it that everybody's had who's had a
long life and been in relationships,
especially Larry King.
Holla at your boy going on number eight.
Was that number seven? They just left
eighth divorce. Seventh wife I
think here he married one of them.
Damn like that. You know
Larry King still alive.
You didn't know. Oh Roy would Roy would,
Roy and I were looking
at pictures of a lacking.
I'm really impressed that he's
still alive. Divorced at 85.
Hawkins more power to him. Get busy. If
you got the money to get divorced at 85,
go for it.
And then shooting him up with steroids
and cocaine and they're just going to
start Viagara just having gals come over
to the place he's over at art's Deli,
holding court. You imagine if, uh,
over the last like year of his life he
just banks and unprecedented volume of
Internet porn and just
releases it all in one blast.
Larry King Fox, he just called it king.
Yes. King sex tapes. Yeah. King. Yeah.
Just Bang it out and just, yeah,
that's how I was going
to get a lot of pictures.
You get so much money if you really
just want money, now's the time to act.
That's wild. Poor Larry.
He doesn't seem like he
has um, good posture.
Like that's not good when you're an
older fellow and he likes the curve,
that curve. He was a very nice
guy. I was on a show at twice.
I was the show twice for fear factor.
So he's very nice, very friendly guy.
You know, he kind of
gotta be when you do that for a living
and every night you're talking no person,
you gotta be good at that Shit
can't be like me. I'd be like, fuck,
I go to jail. Is there a Larry King?
We need to get a Larry King much shot.
Yeah. Get the Larry King Mugshot or
that shit up. Go to take the phone.
You need you five foot of Larry King
Mugshot. How do we not have Larry King?
We just decided to get Pablo Escobar
and need to get the mugshot of the dude
who's still on CNN, who got found
out like in central park in New York,
like with math and like, uh,
like make shift new surround
his dick is, they was, oh,
what the fuck? What's his name?
How do we know the English dude with
the glasses? Uh, dude with glasses. Uh,
a CNN, Richard, um, Richard. Richard.
Come on dude. You're helping to come.
I help to come on to stage
ordering up up large Richard print.
Richard [inaudible]. Oh Man.
You know, as soon as you see
his face you can be like, oh,
that Guy Richard Quest.
Richard quests. Richard Quest.
He's the guy I'm talking about.
I don't know who he is. Oh Dude.
If you see his face, you'll
be like, oh yeah. He's like,
he's like the English guy on CNN.
He got caught and like central park,
we're like meth, like fucking some sort
of noose or something around his dick.
I'm this, as far as I
remember reading, we were,
we were clouding there for a
while. If you're a single gay guy,
isn't that what you're supposed to do? I
don't know. He's supposed to have math.
I don't know. New Tech that's like,
oh no. Is this not on the Internet?
That am I making this up? I was looking
for a mugshot. There's not mugshot,
but here's an explanation
for what happened. Oh,
there's an explanation. Okay,
this next one, she know I'm not
making this up, right? I'm not.
This wasn't like a drug induced like
hallucination or something, right? God,
how hilarious is the way they
put this? CNN personality.
Richard Quest is busting in central park
earlier yesterday with some drugs in
his pocket and a rope wrapped around
his tie and his genitals. No big deal.
And a sex toy in his boot.
Law enforcement official said source
of said quest was initially busted for
loitering. Really wasn't about that.
Aside from the oddly configured rope,
this search also turned up a sex toy
inside of his boot that means his ass hole
and a small bag of methamphetamine
in his left jacket pocket.
It wasn't immediately
clear what the rope was for
[inaudible] shot. You were showing a
picture so he'll know who I'm talking to.
Bobby, please. I'm going to talk
about that on stage from now on.
Send me that guy. Dude, you don't know
that guy. He's all over the fucking CNN.
I do not know that guy. To me,
that article that we just
sent it to my Evernote.
I hope it provides you
something beautiful. Something
there. There's something
this, the best part about the
article, it was not clear.
It was not immediately clear what the
tow rope floor and I'm like, let me help.
Let me help you out.
What does it tighten around
his neck and his dick? What
pocket goes? Mr Quest at 64th street
in west drive at about three Oh,
the police noticed Mr [inaudible]
at 64th street in west drive.
They'll have 3:40 AM the official
said as he was being escorted out,
he volunteered in quotes.
I have meth in my pocket.
According to an official
briefed on the case.
The police searched him and recovered a
small amount of methamphetamine in a zip
lock bag and a rope around his dick
and his neck and a sex bullying.
More importantly, there's a lot of
dudes who do math. Oh, they keep,
I take Chandler and they stay on the
farm or what kind of boots he had on his,
there's a snake in my boot
that means in his asshole. Is this an
English paper? No, this is New York.
It was central park. I
think they mean his asshole.
I don't think they mean his boot or
think they made it his ass. His ass.
That's a whole new dementia. It's your
trunk Bro. They wouldn't call it English,
but it's like this. Isn't
this, this New York Times? Yes.
They using proper British
English. That's America.
That's The New York Times called
boots and boot in American.
Let's go with the better angle on it.
This dude was in his ass and that's fun.
It's the better New York poster.
Do you know our times yet?
It was in his asshole. That's what
it is. Boot his boot. His boot is,
it's proper British for like if
you watch like a that is factual.
That is factual. Clarkson and
fucking Richard Hammonds. James Bay.
They were virtual truck is the best
of boot. Yes. As soon as asshole.
Right. You got sex toys, asshole. Hey,
no judgment brought a whole new
like fucking like dimension to that.
No judgment. Wow. It's okay.
It's fine. Yes sir. Even
if he didn't get caught
with that in his asshole, he's still
doing math and talking to cops. Like what?
The rope around his
Dick and nick. Yeah, that part
too. I was going to get to that.
It was so crazy. Beata of fucking rubber
Dick and his ass like, wait, what?
I'm fighting that shit on [inaudible]
I'll get you that mugshot.
I'm finding it a little math every now
and then. Rob Ran his dick and balls,
whatever
or whatever you got. Not
all charges were dismissed.
Thank God for a man.
You dude is black. Is Wesley
stipes with dreadlocks?
They catch you with a rub. Proud your
Dick and neck with your pocket, Bro. Yeah,
I in jail. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
100% I think so hundred
a hundred dismissed.
You had meth and a rope already connecting
your neck and cock and probably a sex
toy in your ass.
You can't be UK for a different
issue at the very least.
And I was going to say in his shoe,
which is weird enough, it's my,
it might even be weirder, but
let's not jump to conclusions.
[inaudible] confusing interpretation of
the American version of boot and them
saying maybe they think shoe means
ass too. I was with another man.
Oh, maybe nobody's got a fucking
rubber Dick in their boots.
That's outrageous. That would make
your boot off fucking uncomfortable.
Why wouldn't you just put it in
your pocket? It's in his ass, Bro.
Let's just run with this.
He had in his pocket. Shit,
Google search. Shut off all the
computers, spread misinformation.
Look, I'm sure it was just
an issue. Whatever, whatever.
Don't ever volunteer that you have
drugs. Let them find the drugs.
Let them find the drugs. Unless you
want. Fuck the cop. I have a quick, hey,
good one on that.
On that level. Shit on first time
I went to Japan with house pain.
What happened? We were on, you know,
it was one of them things where we
were touring from tour to tour tour.
I would go home and literally take
one set of clothes out of a bag,
thrown in another bag and leave.
So we got to Japan and on this particular
trip I brought my girlfriend at the
time and I think Danny did and lethal
brought his own homie or whatever,
but all the,
we brought a bunch of guests and
everybody gets through customs and as I'm
getting through customs,
the guy reaches into this one jacket
I have and he pulls his hand out and
there's this little nugget of
bud and he's like, what is that?
And I was like, well, can you speak
English? Because he said it in Japanese.
So I said, okay, okay, what is that?
I was like, my brain just was like,
well fuck man, just, it looks like weed.
I said, it looks like we, you know,
I just fucking owned it wherever they
went and got this little test or put some
shit in instead. If it turns blue,
it's weed. I was like, it's weed.
Let's just fucking save a little
trouble. This we, meanwhile,
everybody else had gotten through. They
brought everybody else back in, right?
Fucking gave him the fucking finger.
Like I have like my, my lady,
everything at the time,
everybody got the strip search.
They never strip searched me. They
searched everything. I had all my bags,
everything right? They tested one
nug of weed, whatever. I ended up,
after several hours, the record label
paid off, whatever they ended up pay off.
We got into the country and were able to
do our tour and the point of the story
is everybody fucking hated my guts.
The whole fucking bunch of them.
We get to the hotel.
I'm unpacking my bag and trying to
figure out how the whole fucking thing
happened and I'm looking at the jacket
and I reach into the pocket that was out
of, there's nothing in there.
I was like, fuck, that's crazy.
I reached into the other
pocket of the jacket.
I pulled out a fucking
ounce of fucking weed.
They never looked in the other pocket
of the jacket out fucking ounce of weed.
I Shit, you're done what you wear
without even knowing you were doing it.
You were like sending a small meal to
get busted so that the big ones can sneak
around side.
I must've been rolling a joint somewhat
at the last tour and I had a nug left
over and just thrown it in the pocket,
not thinking about it on one side.
Cartel does that,
but if they would have found out other
ones first I thought I'd be in jail in
motherfucking in Japan for a long
time ever and ever. But I got in,
I called the whole,
I called everybody that smoked in the
crew down to the room after that and I was
like, Yo, check it out man. I really
didn't mean this to happen but
I probably had more good ass fucking
weed in Japan than anybody at the time.
You know what's incredible cause all
they had was hash and shit like that.
Stop and think of that
moment, that moment.
If they didn't go in that one pocket and
they went in the other pocket first and
they found that giant bag of weed, we
wouldn't be having this conversation.
Nope. We probably wouldn't. No, I
don't think so. That's a lot of weed.
Who knows though, in
Japan it would have been,
it took a lot of money to get me out
of the AB regardless a lot instead of,
I think it cost him like 1000
bucks in there, like you know,
which was like 10,000 or something
again or $100 a year post.
Put your lights on. No, this
was in house paint days.
This was like when the only story,
like it was like Paul McCartney is banned
for life because he got caught with
some weed. That's, that was like,
I don't know if it still exists,
but there was a point where he was banned
for life cause he got caught with weed
over there. Wow. Well
you used to be in Nevada,
you get sent to jail for life if you
had weed and now it's legal there. Yeah.
There's a bunch of dudes like looking
out those barred windows dad. Yeah.
That's just got it. Something's
gotta be done about that. That ain't,
that ain't working. Yeah, that's the
problem. That's the number one problem.
Number one problem with laws against
things like we'd like as long as you can
buy some Wizkid's part of the
number one problem. A lot of it too,
as long as these prisons are privatized
and they don't want to let a lot of
these guys go, man,
a lot of these guys get money for the
amount of fucking people in their prisons.
I got a solution. Those private prison
dudes just start selling the weed.
Right. That's not cleaner
way to live your life, man.
Don't be a goddamn slave owner. Slave
owners. This whole leg, urban legend that,
I mean it's very believable about this
letter that went around like a bunch of
people in, in the, in the hip hop
music industry got not, I don't know,
maybe it was within the last decade where
they described like this guy claimed
to be a member of the elite, um,
a class of like executives of the music
business in there in the mid nineties
and whatnot.
And there was a time when the private
prison industry kind of came and got
involved and got a lot of these people
to invest and then kind of help direct
like things like rap music and if you
remember they used to be like public,
I don't know if you were, how
big are you a fan of music?
You were at the time x
clans and public enemies.
There was all these
proactive like you know,
counters to like the party drug dealer
guys or whatever. You know, there was,
there was, there was a nationally,
another side to it that existed and
was successful in flourished, you know,
amongst it, you know, and that
disappeared. But, and like their,
this letter that went around was I kind
of claiming this guy was part of this
thing and he left the meeting
when they, these guys,
it was like a whole conspiracy
thing like you going to,
but it's like totally
believable that the upper could,
these guys would direct a music and a
fucking media in a certain direction to
encourage fucking basically a
cycle of fucking prison for fraud.
Cause if you look at rap music,
if you look at rap music and what
happened from the nineties till now,
there is no conscious music anymore.
There's none. It's um, it's again,
it's, some people will tell you
it's fucking God's honest truth.
So I'm gonna tell you it's the
wildest speculation in the world,
but you can dig it up easily. Kanye
has some conscious music for sure,
but like what? Like Jesus Walks, I'm,
that was written by a guy named, uh,
a rhyme fast, I think is his name.
I think is the guy from Chicago,
one of his partners from Chicago
wrote that song. You know what I mean?
Which guy? Remember these guys are like,
Connie's a producer and I'm
going to say he doesn't write,
but what I'm saying is a lot
of you know, he's also like,
he will take a song and make the song
because he's a producer conscious.
A lot of people do. I'm not just saying
Kanye is like a fraud or anything.
I'm just saying like as
a producer, like people,
Drake doesn't write all his records like,
like it was a different era of rap and
shit like that going on from when I was
young. When I was young,
it was pretty much 90% if you couldn't
call yourself an MC or a rapper,
if you didn't write your own shit,
there were cast it didn't do it.
It's always been there. There's
always been the ghost writing scene.
But if you wanted to walk in a room
and hold down any kind of respect when
people, you had to know, you wrote
your Brian's, you know what I mean?
It's the same in comedy.
Yeah. So it's like, you know,
and it's not saying
like you're not a fraud,
you're just a Democrat of
entertainer. You know what I mean?
As far as I'm concerned, I don't
shit on it. You know what I mean?
There's a lot of Drake records I like,
there's a lot of other shit I like,
you know what I mean? This,
I know those guys didn't write those
records cause I can look at the writer's
credit and see 20 writers
credits on it. So, but I come
from there era of like, you know,
you gotta write your Shit. Yeah.
I think some people feel
the value of collaboration,
which is a legitimate thing.
And if your ego is good enough
where you can like work with,
like Paul Mooney worked
with prior, you know,
prior is the greatest of all time in my
opinion. And he, he worked with Mooney.
Mooney helped him a lot,
you know, and Richard,
Jenny worked with Chris Rock and you
know, and others as well, you know,
like this, it's not like some
of the greatest of all time.
I've had people that work with them and
oh my God, that's, he's the greatest.
He's like, he sees my most important uh,
important influencers. When I,
when I was at the comedy store,
because he was like the first guy
that I felt like it was a real,
I was scared of him cause I knew he
worked for prior. I knew he was like,
he's connected to royalty and he'd be
around the comedy store and I'd just
feeding it still sharp is or a
female. It's still right there.
That's when I was in like
my twins and he laughed.
One time I was in, I was on stage
in front of like 10 people in,
I was doing my act and I
heard it in the back of it.
Ah, ah.
And then he came up to me afterwards
and he said that you were funny
motherfucker. He goes, you, you did
that shit. Like it was a sold out room.
He goes, you're a real
comic. And I was like, wow.
Like Paul Mooney said that to me.
Cause I remember he was connected.
He's connected to the fucking, the man.
He was connected to prize made like all
those, the like it's the contribution,
like it's, I mean I guess it might be,
maybe it's different in hip hop but,
but in standup it's similar that we,
there's guys like Bill Burr
who writes everything he says.
Everything he says is coming
from a bill. Birthplace of my,
he's not contributing with anybody. He's
not, you know, he's not collaborating.
He's just, he's just being built
by, you know, Joey Diaz, same thing.
Like absolutely everything that
guy says coming out of his head.
There's something extra to that, you
know, it doesn't sound better or worse.
It's just like you'd go into,
it's like difference between you
going to a restaurant and everything's
homemade.
It might be the same as if everything
wasn't homemade in terms of like the way
it tastes, but not the
way it feels. Right.
Like you got like you
writes your own shit.
Like when you write your own
shit and you play your own songs,
it's like I'm getting a piece of you.
I'm getting a little piece of you
comes out of your art and that's,
that's the difference. It's not like
does anything wrong with collaboration?
Collaboration is, look, if
you look at Chris rock stuff,
it's arguably some of the greatest
work of all time in terms of like the
finished product of standby, stand
up comedy bigger and blacker.
It's one of the greatest comedy specials
in the history of the world. Period.
End of discussion. Anybody that
argues with you as an asshole,
so that came out of collaborative
efforts. It's nothing wrong with that.
Obviously you made something amazing and
many other bits and many other things
that a lot of great comics have done,
but it is different, man. It's different,
you know, but we're all,
some will in some way connected to each
other and collaborating with each other
whether we like it or not.
It's not like the the as like
how many stages into the game?
Where are they going to
collaborate with you?
Are they going to be there
for the final product?
Are they just going to be influences all
along the way in your artistic journey?
Well, yeah, it means a lot
of words. Even the most,
they'd be the thing that I would consider
that I wrote completely by myself.
If you want it, if you get
down to the next level,
it's like there's 25,000 things that
have influenced why I think that way or
feel that way. What I mean, so
that's determined. That's why I,
that said the whole angle of
like there's really nothing new.
It's all about the angle. And,
and I liken it to like when
I watched two a I like,
I like watching the, um, old, uh, uh, uh,
a dog town like documentaries,
dog town and the z boys and shit.
And it's like the whole
approach to skating was like,
everybody can do that, but it's the
style you do it in. You know what I mean?
That's what it really starts coming
down to. There's not many, again,
if there's no brand new
invention or brand new event,
we're rehashing experiences that are,
that have been happening
since the dawn of time.
And you're just finding a new style
at a new angle to dress it up.
And that makes people feel like
it's new. Sure. Sorrow, romance,
love. That's
you're breaking the boredom of the way
it's been thought of before in a new way.
And that's what becomes
appealing to people.
The goddamn when someone hits
it and they do get through
with something, that's a new way of
describing some shit we can all relate to.
Makes you feel so good. Like music
makes you feel good in a way.
The comedy never can.
Like comedy makes you laugh and it
makes you have a good time together.
We're all in a room laughing, hooting it
up. But music, when you're by yourself,
man, you can just be, it's just be you
and that music can you get goosebumps?
You can lift more weights. You run
faster. Like if fires you up, man.
If I'm running hills and
I'm listening to music,
I honestly feel like I'm cheating.
I feel like I'm cheating because I feel
like I take this like burst of like
artificial energy. It's not dependent
upon my discipline or drive.
It's not artificial though. I know
it's not, but it's, I didn't make it.
Yeah, no, but again, see,
I don't know if it's,
some grass is greener shit and I don't,
I don't even know if
that's the proper phrase,
but like just when I
look at as an art form,
you like that comparison when you're
like, it's good music is this. I'm like,
comedy is so much more precious because
you work it to that point and even if
you tell an amazing joke that lives
in me and I fucking love it so much,
I take it and tell it to him for me,
the minute I tell it to him, its ends,
it's like that's the end of that joke
from me. You know what I mean? It's,
it's like there's a preciousness
today. It's like a fucking,
to me like there's a finite, you're
creating an art that's like a,
it's like almost like a dude who creates
art just to fucking watch it. Like,
yeah, Yup, Yup.
I did it like as some Japanese lantern
that's going to just go up and flames and
fucking disappear. It's like
there's a beauty in that.
That to me is far different
and far more again,
precious because it's,
it's life is shorter.
You have to watch it and that's my point
is like you have to watch an idea of
yours come to a finite end. Whereas I,
when an idea of mine comes to a finite
end and it's good and it connects,
it can, I can repeat it over and over and
over and people accept that, you know,
so it's not, it's just a bit to me
it's just the, the preciousness of it.
You understand? What I'm
getting at is like wow,
that was that all that work for
that. For the, it's like the limp.
It's almost like the Olympic
athlete training his old life.
Like that's how each joke almost is when
you write it. When I, the way I allow,
I've watched a lot of economy,
I'm fucking them all over all
y'all motherfuckers shit on the,
when they post specials bill, all those
dudes, I'm Tony, I'm mind all this shit.
So it's like I'm really a fan of
comedy and it's just amazing to me.
Like I said, the finite, this
stuff it is is, is precious,
but that's an interesting
way of putting it.
I never really thought about that way.
I thought about it in the way that like
you have to write new stuff that I'd
never thought about it in a way that like
the first time that someone hears it,
that's the only time they
really hear it every night.
Every time after that they know what's
coming. They never see it the same way.
You know? It's like, again,
like an Olympic athlete,
you're working that joke, you're
working that joke out and your work,
the jokes getting better
and it's like, okay,
it's a bronze metal joke right
now and it's a silver manager.
If you ever get it to that gold metal
joke and then you drop it where it's
supposed to be in that place in time of
this special or the thing that everybody
sees, then it's done.
You know what's interesting now
is there's a lot of comedy nerds.
They want to watch the process is the
watch it flip punch lines around and flip
things around and they go, hey, you did
that thing different now I go, yeah,
I'm trying to figure out how to do it.
That'd be amazing to me if I had the
time to just sit and watch you guys work
out like go to the comedy
club every night or whatever.
These two ladies from Arizona
and they came down to the store,
they travel around the world,
they want to see Ari in Europe or
Iceland or some shit, but their,
their comedy nerds and they
come to watch and they'll like,
they'll see you like two months
ago and then they come see again.
I had conversations with them
and I'm like, yeah, I like,
I switched that up like you
put that there. I'm like, yeah,
I'm trying to figure out where to put
it. I don't know where that got hurt on.
My point is like there's a journey there
until you get to that point where it's
like dropped in that special or the
thing that's been seen across broad
spectrum,
it is a journey and they know that
because they're fans of the comedy,
so they know there's things that thing's
gonna that thing's going to build into
something, you know? That's
cool. I would love again, that's,
that sounds like a fucking
amazing time to me.
It's also like if you're a fan of music,
it's hard to go watch people practice.
It's different. Yeah.
Because you're practicing in front of
motherfuckers and they're reacting.
I'm practicing what we
do. We call it shedding.
Cause we're locked in a fucking room doing
it by ourselves and we ain't going to
do it in front of you until we got that
shit right. You know, we can't do that.
We have to do it in front
of people. But the weird,
the weird thing about it is it's like
a, like they can come and see it.
They can see practice. No, that's not,
people can't see you practice. Really.
It's not practice. You're just
fucking perform. It's proof.
Comedy's performance art, you
know what I mean? Yeah, for sure.
So it's like you're working
it out. You have the concept,
but it has to be worked out. It has to
be walked to a destination so to speak.
You know what I mean? The
other part of it is though,
there's so many more people doing
music from the rod doing comedy,
like the waters are like less
populated. What do you think?
Like the numbers for sure.
Right? Absolutely. Because hey,
more great bands and there are great
Camino. There's not a lot of great bands.
There's a lot of fucking artists. Like
there's not a lot of new and great bands.
Name a couple new gray
pants. Oh yeah. Okay. I saw,
I thought we were talking
about like coming,
you know the mailers for
all active currently. Yeah.
Do the rolling stones are still on
tour? What the fuck is happening?
They just waiting for someone to explode.
The funny thing was I think I went to
their farewell tour and like fucking
blossom and everybody back then
was saying, isn't it amazing?
They're still touring amazing
Aerosmith too. Same deal.
They were probably in their 50s then
you know now what the like seventies
eighties, David Lee Roth looks healthy
as fuck. It was funny when you were,
you had him in his, uh, in your
lyrics. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Dude,
he's healthy as fuck, man. That guy
has no connection to the outside world.
He has a lady he uses.
The lady has a phone. She,
she tells David where he should
go and when did she meet you?
David goes there and David
doesn't bring a phone.
I don't even know if he had a wallet. I
paid for dinner. I'm like, this guy is,
he's not connected at all to give a
fuck smiles and everybody couldn't be
friendlier. He just knows his vibration.
He figured it out and he
sticks with it. Can't, hey,
he's hilarious, man. He's a fascinating
cat that David Lee Roth, you know,
he lived in Japan for like
a year and learned Kendo,
which is the art of sword fighting,
trained under a Japanese mastery,
brought his dog, renting an apartment,
got a fucking apartment in Tokyo,
and just every day went to Kendo.
Practice got whacked with bamboo swords.
My, my, one of my traumas,
the guy, he's a fish,
he's actually the band fish bone
into one of the namesakes and uh,
uh, he's into all that, like heavy
Jujitsu, but like martial arts.
But he's weapons trained.
Like how many people move to Japan
to train with a Japanese Kendo master
for a fucking year? He
didn't even speak Japanese.
He brings his dog to the other side of
the planet to learn sword fighting for a
year. And he's David Lee Roth and
he learned of these things. Oh,
he learned a lot of shit. Yeah, he
can speak like a broken version,
I'm sure of of Japanese, but I
bet his candles pretty bad ass.
I don't want a sword fight him.
He really went for it. You know,
he trained a martial arts and
karate and kickboxing under Benny,
her or Ketos Benny the jet or Kitezh
who was like a California legend,
a worldly Jim like in Van Nuys ran
eyes. When I first came to California,
there's two things that I needed to do.
I needed to go to the comedy
store first and foremost.
Number two is I needed
to go to the jet center.
The jet center was bending
the jets. Place a van.
I shot my first album cover
there. Did you really?
I'm pretty sure that's what
year, like 1988 oh my God.
I wasn't out here yet. That's crazy.
I was just starting the first ever
last record with ice tea. Iced tea,
like had a sign. Wow, that's
crazy. The label. Yeah.
I got here too late man.
I got here in 94 and the gym had been
so badly damaged by the earthquake that
when it started raining was
a year after the earthquake.
When it started raining, the rain was
leaking all throughout the ceiling.
The ceiling was a wreck and they had
abandoned the building and I don't think
they ever,
they started off another place in north
Hollywood but it wasn't quite the same
thing.
Like the jet center in Van Nuys was like
one of those places where I'm positive.
No, that's where it is. Cause
it's a boxing ring like,
and I remember the Jetson
incident, that's where we shot it.
That's how I knew about banks. And all.
That's how I learned about tough dudes,
man. I went there,
I was so nervous cause I came here from
New York and I was still sparring back
then.
I had decided to stop sparring yet I
just needed something to do and I was out
here doing TV work and I was training
with all these gang bangers. Man.
I remember this one dude, he
had something on his back,
I don't remember what he,
what the name of the gang was,
let's like flopped us
or something like that.
And then it just said
fuck the rest on his back.
And I remember thinking Jesus and one of
the guys like blinky Rodriguez who was
a world class world championship level
kickboxer he knocked out Johnny Terrio.
He was like a,
like top of the food chain kickboxer he
had a son that succumb to gang violence
and so he like worked really, I'm
sure. Pretty sure this is a story.
And he worked really
hard to like help the,
the gang members in the community and
bring them in the gym for free and teach
them kickboxing and show them that they
have value in that they get work out
their differences inside the ring
like men and not get involved in gang
violence, check test.
And so it was a weird thing because
we'd go there and he was like,
you're taking kickpop on the fucking
kid from the suburbs of Boston. Okay.
And I'm a comedian and I'm like fucking
26 years old and I'm hanging out with
gang bangers and there's like hardcore
kickboxing gym of one of my martial arts
idols, Benny or Kitezh. And another one,
blinky Rodriguez was another one of
my martial arts idols and you know,
they didn't know who the fuck I was and
I was just in there like training with
them. And then it went
under and I was like,
if I got this brief glimpse into
this place that was in my childhood,
like my, my martial arts childhood,
like that was one of the
MCAS that I need to go to.
I needed to go drays the jet center,
but it just all went away real quick.
Like within, I don't know, I don't know
how many months after I joined there.
One was forever everlasting. Me
Like in a corner of a building,
cause they had the Everlast
they had me in a boxing ring.
Then just fucking [inaudible]. That
was the jet center. We shot that.
It's Benny. The jet was nasty.
There it is. You Go, wow.
That's actually my father. That's my
father on the, on the upper right there.
Dude. I bought that. Guaranteed.
I bought that CD 100% a
hundred percent I bought that.
So that was all with the jet center
man. Wow. That guy was a legend man.
Benny or Ketos was a beast.
He would go to Hawaiian fighting these
crazy mixed tournaments or they do judo
on you and boxing and all kinds of crazy
shit. These guys were the originators,
man. They were the hardcore second
wave after Bruce [inaudible].
Damn handsome bastard.
God Damn He, look dude,
I got like a little Hitler stash
or something going on there.
What would I think? I
was trying to grow it.
I looked like a quarterback in
a movie like a high school movie
Burley Asshole who I was I
think 16 right there, man.
That shot is taken by a
legendary photographer.
Don't name by the name of Glen
Friedman. Man. He took many,
many of the most iconic shots
ever do. Shout out to Glenn.
You would play a perfect guy in like a
movie about a quarterback was an asshole
to his girlfriend. There's
another guy in the,
in the school and he's like real sensitive
and he writes poetry and the girl
wants to be with him like want to kick
his ass. Yeah, that's you right there.
Bullying. Yeah. Listen man,
this lady is fuck right.
2120 to seven. You want to put
one more song and get Outta here?
Let's do a and break it down.
Break it down. Everybody. Um,
DJ MLO please keep up your
credentials and social media.
Jay Melody is DJ Melody.
DJ Melodie on Instagram.
And like I said, beat junkies.
Institute the sound. Check it out.
And a all on Instagram, Twitter, all
that jazz. They could find it from there.
Yes sir. Why do fours house
or pain is the album? Woo.
All these songs are
from that and uh, yeah,
we got one more for you. Play
you out. Hi Buddy. You Ready?
[inaudible]
sandwich. You're alone. Mammoth effort.
Got Memphis on my mind
cause now been college. His heart
broken old bull. Stanford's
[inaudible] still mad.
[inaudible] happened driving Oh,
miles in this whole little shit.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
uh,
Joe Rogan experience.
[inaudible] DJ Melo D.
Thank you guys. That was awesome. Thank
you brother. That was a good dancer.
It was beautiful.
Beautiful. Get on everybody.
Woo.